Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 164. Mein Name wie immer Tim Pritlove und ja eine weitere Sendung hier direkt aus der Metaebene in eure Ohrmuscheln hinein und ja heute steht ein kantiges Thema auf dem Programm, was ich auch schon so lange vor mir her schiebe, wo ich immer so ein bisschen auf den richtigen Moment gewartet habe, von dem ich jetzt hoffe, dass er auch gekommen ist. Es geht ums Urheberrecht, kantige Geschichte und ja, wie sich schon leicht ausrechnen lässt, habe ich mal Matthias, Matthias Spielkamp, gebeten, dazu zu stoßen zu diesem Thema. Hallo Matthias.
Hallo Tim.
Ja, du bist jemand, der verschickt E-Mails, wo am Ende ein Link ist auf AGBs.
Das ist was, äh, schlechte Erfahrungen gemacht.
Natürlich, mit E-Mails?
Nein, nicht mit E-Mails in dem Sinne, aber also der Grund, warum ich überhaupt angefangen habe, mich mit Urheberrecht zu beschäftigen, als journalistisches Thema, war, dass ich als Journalist gearbeitet habe und auf einmal sogenannte Total Buyout-Geschäftsbedingungen zugesendet bekommen habe von Verlagen. Damals war es der Berliner Verlag und der süddeutsche Verlag, die alle Rechte von mir wollten und kein bisschen Honorar mehr dafür bezahlen. Und dann gab es eben das Problem, das ist immer der Streitfall, ist, wessen Geschäftsbedingungen gelten. Also man muss im Grunde genommen schon bei der Absprache des Auftrags klar machen, dass die eigenen Geschäftsbedingungen gelten und nicht die des Verlags, wenn man solchen Dingen entkommen will.
Verstehe.
Das heißt, da bin ich in gewisser Weise aus Schaden klug geworden. Aber ob das hilft tatsächlich, das was da drinsteht in meinen E-Mails, das kann ich nicht so genau sagen. Also es hat mir schon geholfen, in dem ich einfach, nachdem mir gesagt wurde, so und jetzt möchten wir damit machen, was wir wollen, habe ich ihnen gesagt, tut mir leid, aber wenn sie in meine E-Mail reingucken, dann sehen sie, dass ich ihnen meine Geschäftsbedingungen zur Kenntnis gegeben habe. Und dann kam auch nie wieder was.
Aber die hat man ja damit noch nicht gleich akzeptiert, oder? Ja, das ist so wie so eine Drogerie. So wenn sie hier reinkommen, haben sie implizit zugestimmt, dass wir ihnen 100 Euro abknöpfen, wenn sie was klauen und wir erwischen sie.
Ja, also implizit nicht. Aber es ist schon so, dass tatsächlich das passieren kann oder dass normalerweise davon ausgegangen wird, dass solche Geschäftsbedingungen nur zur Kenntnis gegeben werden müssen. Das ist ja im Grunde genommen ähnlich wie so eine sogenannte Click-Rap-License, mit der ja sicher viele, die hier zuhören, vertraut sind. Das heißt, man installiert eine neue Software und dann steht da drin, jetzt sind das hier die Geschäftsbedingungen. Die können sie lesen. Das macht nie jemand, weil das 80 Seiten kleingedrucktes Juristensprech ist. Und dann macht man den Haken drunter und dann sind die halt zur Kenntnis gegeben worden und dann hat man die akzeptiert. Und tatsächlich kann es einem so ähnlich passieren mit diesen Geschäftsbedingungen eben auch im Geschäft mit Verlagen und dergleichen. Das heißt, wenn man davon ausgehen kann, dass die Geschäftsbedingungen zur Kenntnis gegeben worden sind und die unwidersprochen bleiben, dann gelten die eben wirklich. Also das wird dann von den Verlagen auch häufig so gemacht, dass sie die Geschäftsbedingungen in Kurzform oder nicht in Kurzform, sondern dass sie die relativ kurz und knapp formulieren und auf die Abrechnung mit drauf schreiben. Das heißt, man bekommt irgendwann eine Abrechnung, soll dann praktisch nachträglich den Geschäftsbedingungen zugestimmt haben und natürlich für alle Zukunft. Und es ist eben je nach Fall so, dass es sein kann, dass man damit tatsächlich auch eben eingestimmt hat und dass man große Schwierigkeiten hat, da wieder rauszukommen später. Da hat man dann vor allen Dingen ein Beweisproblem. Also wessen Geschäftsbedingungen galten zu dem Zeitpunkt, als der Auftrag abgesprochen wurde und dergleichen mehr. In der Situation war ich selber mal, weil ich mich dagegen wehren wollte, dass ganz viele meiner Texte in einer Genius-Datenbank aufgetaucht sind, ohne dass ich dem jemals zugestimmt habe. Und das Verfahren, bei dem Verdi tatsächlich auch Rechtsschutz gewährt hätte, wäre aber so kompliziert gewesen, dass ich die Finger davon gelassen habe. Ja, die Genius-Datenbank ist einer der ganz großen Datenbankbetreiber in Deutschland. GBI Genius, die sind inzwischen fusioniert. Das waren zwei und die haben eine sehr große Presse-Datenbank. Und darüber gab es in der Vergangenheit viel Streit. Gibt es sicherlich im Moment auch weiterhin, weil dort passiert, was in der digitalen Welt eigentlich selbstverständlich ist, dass es irgendwo einen Ort gibt, wo man alle möglichen Presseartikel nachträglich abrufen kann. Gegengeld in dem Fall. Und viele Verlage haben sich insofern daran beteiligt, dass sie ihre Archive zur Verfügung stellen und Genius macht die eben zugänglich. Und dann kann man dort diese Artikel abrufen. Und die Autoren werden daran im Regelfall nicht beteiligt, auch wenn da Geld fließt. Und das geht so weit, dass man zum Beispiel bei Texten, die im Grunde genommen entweder urheberrechtsfrei sind oder bei denen sogar klar ist, dass die Urheberrechte woanders liegen, nämlich beim Autor, dass die in dieser Genius-Datenbank zu finden sind. Also ein bekannter Fall ist sowas wie die Nobelpreisrede von Günther Gras. Die war jetzt nicht bei Genius. Also die hätte man über Genius auch finden können. Die war in erster Linie im FAZ-Archiv. Und die konnte man auch syndizieren, wie das so schön blöd Neudeutsch heißt. Das heißt, man kann also auf der Seite selber einfach sagen, ich will die jetzt auf meine Website stellen. Und dann muss man an die FAZ bezahlen. Günther Gras hat aber selbstverständlich nie seine Zustimmung dazu gegeben. Also es ist ein Urheberrechtsverstoß, im Grunde genommen sogar ein gewerblicher Urheberrechtsverstoß, der in dem Fall mit Haft bis zu fünf Jahren belegt werden könnte. Es ist ein bisschen schade, dass Günther Gras selber nie dagegen geklagt hat. Aber der Perlentaurer hat sich mal einen Spaß daraus gemacht, das tatsächlich zu kaufen und dann auch darüber zu schreiben.
Was hat das dann gekostet?
Oh, die Preise kenne ich nicht, muss ich sagen. Das ist tatsächlich sehr dynamisch. Eigentlich vom Geschäftsmodell recht clever. Da kann man gar nicht groß meckern. Die haben das ganz gut gemacht in dem Sinne, dass sich das dann abhängig danach bestimmt, wie viel Seiten aufrufe, wie lange das zu sehen sein soll und dergleichen mehr. Also der Teil ist eigentlich ganz, ganz gut gemacht. Das ist das, was man sich so wünscht. Wenn sie jetzt noch eine API hätten, dann wären wir glücklich. Das Problem ist nur, dass die Rechte eigentlich nicht geklärt sind, sondern dass sie das einfach alles machen und implizit die Zustimmung des Autors voraussetzen.
Ja, schöne Geschichte zum Start. Die macht schnell wieder klar, das Ganze ist irgendwie ein Tohuwa-Bohu. Das ist zumindest der Eindruck, der sich da immer erklärt. Dann gibt es viele Veranstaltungen, wo viel darüber geredet wird. Nicht selten bist du auch dabei. Du wirst ja so als Experte gehandelt. Das lässt dich grinsen.
Ja, das lässt mich grinsen, weil ich schon natürlich auf eine Art zum Experten geworden bin. Ich beschäftige mich jetzt seit sieben Jahren ungefähr mit dem Thema und habe das auch so zu meinem journalistischen Kernthema gemacht. Aber auf dem Feld Experte zu sein, ist natürlich sehr schwierig. Die meisten Juristen, die sich auf Urheberrecht spezialisiert haben, die kann man natürlich mit Fug und Recht als Experten bezeichnen. Da ist es dann aber wiederum so, dass andere Aspekte, die beim Urheberrecht und in der Debatte über das Urheberrecht eine große Rolle spielen, nämlich Kultur, Autorschaft, Ökonomie und so weiter, dass das nur wieder gerade nicht die Expertengebiete der Juristen sind, aber die, da es sich um ein Rechtsgebiet handelt, das eben im Gesetz festgelegt ist, nehmen für sich in Anspruch, dass sie eben die Urheberrechtsexperten sind. Manche tun das mit Bescheidenheit und sagen, ich habe mich damit einfach sehr lange meines Lebens beschäftigt und ich will meinen Teil dazu beitragen. Andere sind da, sagen wir mal so, ein bisschen arroganter und gehen davon aus, dass jeder, der jetzt nicht als Jurist sich aufs Urheberrecht spezialisiert hat, da eigentlich nicht mitreden darf. Was aber insgesamt, denke ich, ein gesellschaftliches Problem heutzutage ist, denn Recht ist nun mal ein bestimmender Systemanteil geworden. Und wenn man sich anschaut, wie viele Juristen im Bundestag sitzen und das natürlich über die Gesetzgebung ganz stark Einfluss, also sicherlich, dass die Gesetzgebung das Mittel ist, in dem sich ja im Grunde genommen in Gesellschaft selber ihre Regeln gibt, dass da der Einfluss von Juristen natürlich immens groß ist. Das ist nicht nur im Urheberrecht so, das ist auch in allen anderen Gebieten so.
Das ist richtig. Aber du bist sozusagen mehr so, Experte in Anführungsstrichen, aber aus so einer journalistischen Perspektive heraus.
Genau. Ich habe mir damals gedacht, es ist ein sehr komplexes Thema, aber vor allen Dingen auch ein politisch sehr relevantes Thema. Und das war zu der Zeit, als ich damit angefangen habe, jetzt nicht neu. Gerade im US-amerikanischen Raum war das schon lange eine Debatte, aber in Deutschland auch. Es gab ja schon Konferenzen dazu, es gab Debatten darüber. Sagen wir mal Teildebatten, wie etwa über Autorschaft gibt es ja ohnehin schon viel, viel länger. Aber über diese explizite Urheberrechtsfrage gab es auch zu der Zeit schon Debatten. Allerdings muss man sagen, dass die kaum in Publikumsmedien stattgefunden haben. Und das war schon mein Ansatz, dass ich gesagt habe, ich möchte eigentlich in Publikumsmedien, heißt also in Magazinen, Tageszeitungen, im Radio, vielleicht sogar im Fernsehen, mit dazu beitragen, dass klar wird, dass es sich hier um ein politisch sehr, sehr relevantes Thema handelt. Inzwischen ist das selbstverständlich geworden, aber zu der Zeit war es das noch nicht. Also ich war da jetzt nicht die Avantgarde, aber von den Journalisten war ich sicherlich einer der ersten, der sich damit in diesem Maße beschäftigt hat. Ja, vor sieben Jahren. Also wie gesagt, Leute wie Monika Ermat oder Stefan Krempel oder so, die hatten da schon jahrelang dazu gearbeitet zu dem Zeitpunkt und jetzt ist, finde ich zum Beispiel, dass Heise Online oder die CT jetzt auch nicht ein Fachmagazin ist, wie etwa die Zeitschrift Schüttgut oder dergleichen, aber es ist jetzt, es richtet sich natürlich schon an einen sehr informierten Kreis von Lesern. Und das ist nun mal bei Brandeins und der Berliner Zeitung und der Süddeutschen ein bisschen was anderes. Und ich habe eben versucht, für die auch diese Themen dann mehr in den Vordergrund zu rücken.
Ja, hier gibt es auch sehr informierte Hörer.
Ja, das glaube ich.
Davon kann man sicher ausgehen. Insofern ist das Thema hier, glaube ich, ganz gut platziert. Bleiben wir noch mal kurz in der Vergangenheit. Ihr habt ja dann irgendwann, also ihr, du und andere, iRights.info gestartet, so eben mit dem Ziel, quasi die Urheberrechtsproblematiken in der neuen Zeit, im digitalen Zeitalter, wie man so schön sagt. Furchtbares Wort. Ja, aufzuklären. Ist euch das gelungen?
Ja und nein. Also, ich glaube schon, dass es uns ansatzweise gelungen ist. Es ist überhaupt schon mal ein wahnsinniger Erfolg gewesen, dass das überhaupt zustande gekommen ist. Also Volker Grasmuk, der damals die Idee hatte, ist ja einer von denjenigen, die sich eben schon viel länger mit diesen Urheberrechtsfragen beschäftigt hatte als ich. Und der auch von Anfang an diese politischen Implikationen gesehen hat und das aus dem Grunde gemacht hat. Der ist ja auch kein Jurist zum Beispiel und hat gesagt, das hat eine solche Auswirkung auf unsere Kultur und auf unsere Gesellschaft, dass wir darüber eine öffentliche Debatte brauchen. Und damals ging eben gerade die Auseinandersetzung um den sogenannten ersten Korb, also die Urheberrechtsnovelle in Deutschland, los. Und er hat gesagt, wir brauchen Informationsangebot dazu, bei dem eben darüber berichtet wird und bei dem sich unter Umständen auch diejenigen, die davon betroffen sind, also die Bürgerinnen und Bürger, daran beteiligen können. Und er hat es geschafft, das beim Verbraucherschutzministerium unterzubringen damals. Die haben das gefördert am Anfang, anderthalb Jahre lang. Und es gab auch ganz gut Geld. Also das war jetzt, man konnte damit natürlich nicht reich werden, das ist klar, aber allein die Tatsache, dass man mal anderthalb Jahre an etwas arbeiten kann und praktisch eine halbe Stelle bezahlt bekommt, das war schon ein enormer Startvorteil. Und ich würde sagen, es ist uns insofern gelungen, dass wir zumindest innerhalb der Community von Leuten, die sich mit dem Thema befassen, viel Aufmerksamkeit erregt haben. Wir haben immerhin den Grimme Online Award dafür bekommen 2006 mit einer sehr schönen Jurybegründung, die uns damals alle wirklich gefreut hat, weil die ganz genau auch darauf abgezielt haben, zu sagen oder ganz genau gesagt haben, ja, das ist ein sehr politisch relevantes Thema. Und es ist ein Thema, über das in der Gesellschaft eine Debatte passieren muss. Und dazu trägt iRights eben bei. Und das auch noch mit Texten, die so geschrieben sind, dass man sie als lei eben auch verstehen kann. Das ist ja die große Herausforderung, diese Rechtsthemen so zu formulieren, dass sie nicht nur verständlich sind, sondern vielleicht sogar ein bisschen unterhaltsam. Also dass man sich nicht durch Texte und Erklärungen durchquälen muss, sondern dass man die vielleicht sogar mit ein bisschen Freude liest und denkt, ach, das ist schön, da habe ich mal wieder was verstanden oder mal wieder was gelernt. Und wenn uns das gelingt, dann ist uns schon viel gelungen. Dass wir natürlich keine Millionen Seiten-Aufrufe am Tag haben, das ist auch irgendwie klar. Und man muss auch dazu sagen, wir arbeiten jetzt inzwischen schon wieder seit mehr als anderthalb Jahren und haben auch zwischendurch ehrenamtlich gearbeitet. Das heißt, wir bekommen immer nur punktuell eine Förderung, wenn wir mal eine Veranstaltung machen oder vielleicht eine Publikation produzieren. Aber das andere, also so eine Grundförderung wie vom Verbraucherschutzministerium haben wir eben nicht. Und das ist schwierig. Also es ist einfach sehr schwierig, dann so eine Plattform, die eigentlich den Anspruch hat, auch ein bisschen aktuell zu sein, aber eben auch ausführliche und rechtlich abgesicherte Erklärtexte drauf zu haben, die zu betreiben, das ist einfach sehr, sehr viel Arbeit. Und da scheitern wir inzwischen eben auch manchmal dran, also an unseren eigenen Ansprüchen.
Ja, die Vergütung im Web für Tätigkeiten, sicherlich ein Thema, was wir auch nochmal anschneiden können, jetzt hier im Rahmen des Gesprächs. Ja, das heißt, du hast dich jetzt im Prinzip über diese lange Zeit quasi in dieses Thema reingearbeitet. Was hast du denn so für einen Eindruck, wie sich so der Rest der Gesellschaft in das Thema reingearbeitet hat?
Na, hauptsächlich natürlich über die großen Aufregerthemen, Tauschbörsen, vor allen Dingen da in dem Fall Pirate Bay. Das ist etwas, was viel Aufmerksamkeit erregt hat. Das fand ich war so ein ganz entscheidender Punkt, den ich selber gemerkt habe, bemerkt habe. An dem Tag, als das Pirate Bay-Urteil verkündet wurde, habe ich, glaube ich, vier Radio-Interviews gegeben oder so was in der Größenordnung. Das lag jetzt, also das Ich-es-Wahl lag daran, dass die Kollegen im Urlaub oder auf Geschäftsreise oder so waren und nicht konnten. Aber wir haben einfach insgesamt vier oder fünf Anfragen bekommen, an diesem Freitag und an dem Samstag. Und da habe ich dann wirklich gemerkt, also es ist zumindest jetzt in den Massenmedien angekommen. Dass es natürlich am nächsten Tag wieder verschwunden ist, ist auch klar. Aber auch das unterscheidet ja dieses Thema nicht von anderen Themen, die eben auch einmal hochgejässt werden. Und am nächsten Tag sind sie wieder weg und irgendwann kommen sie wieder auf die Tagesordnung. Und dann gibt es andere Themen, Google Books zum Beispiel. Street View hat ja jetzt nichts mit Urheberrecht oder so gut wie gar nichts mit Urheberrecht zu tun. Aber dieses Google-Buch-Projekt schon. Und das hat auch noch mal eine große Aufmerksamkeit erregt. Der Heidelberger Appell, diese Dinge. Da ist es schon wirklich dann raus aus diesem Ghetto-Fachzeitschriften und so weiter. Leider eben auch mit den entsprechenden Konsequenzen. Das heißt, es wird dann oft genug auch sehr vereinfacht. Ich bin Journalist. Ich verstehe das. Ich weiß, dass man vereinfachen muss, um Themen zu erklären. Aber oft genug stört es mich dann doch auch, wie es die Kollegen machen. Und das ist jetzt nicht unbedingt persönlich gemeint. Also in den meisten Fällen ist es nicht persönlich gemeint, in dem Sinne, dass ich sage, das sind schlechte Journalisten. Sondern ich kenne das Mediengeschäft. Ich war bei einer Pressekonferenz zum zweiten Korb, also der zweiten Urheberrechtsnovelle. Und habe da gehört, wie die Kollegen darüber gesprochen haben, in der Lobby vom Justizministerium. Und das waren fast alles Leute, die an dem Tag davon erfahren haben, dass sie auf diese Pressekonferenz gehen sollten und dann einen Beitrag darüber machen. Und die haben dann auch entsprechend TUM-Befragen gestellt und sich da auch wirklich alles verkaufen lassen in dieser Pressekonferenz. Und das ist einerseits bitter, das so mitzubekommen. Und andererseits ist es eben aber auch leider normal. Also es ist auch nicht unerwartet.
Das ist aber schon ein bisschen merkwürdig, wenn ausgerechnet die Journalisten in so einem Thema, was sie nun ureigens betrifft, da nicht in der Lage sind, so eine erste Garde vorzuschieben. Oder überhöhe ich jetzt die Bedeutung dieser Pressekonferenz?
Ja, also ich habe mich damals sehr geärgert. Und als ich dann hinterher die dpa-Meldung gelesen habe, da musste ich auch wirklich sagen, daran war im Grunde genommen nichts richtig. Also das ist noch ein bisschen was anderes, als zu sagen, das war alles falsch. Aber wenn man sich die kurze Meldung jetzt angeguckt hat, dann konnte man praktisch an jedem Faktum, was da irgendwie drin vermeintlich verkauft wurde, konnte man sagen, also so ganz stimmt das jetzt nicht. Und in manchen Fällen stimmte es auch gar nicht. Und das ist schon sehr ärgerlich. Aber nein, ich glaube jetzt nicht, das sagen wir mal so, das ist innerhalb der Branche, ist das auch ja durchaus umstritten. Man will sich als Journalist jetzt nicht unbedingt mit Urheberrecht beschäftigen, nur weil man was macht, was im Grunde genommen dadurch reguliert wird. Das wäre ja so wie zu sagen, jeder Filmemacher, jeder Musiker und so weiter muss eigentlich Lust haben, sich mit dem Urheberrecht zu beschäftigen. Das ist ja überhaupt nicht so. Und es ist im Grunde genommen schade, dass man es heute machen muss. Also das bedeutet ja im Grunde genommen, dass man auf alles achten muss, weil man sonst über einen Löffel balbiert wird.
Die Programmierer, die setzen sich ja auch mit Softwarepartiten auseinander.
Ja, das ist auch ein großes Vorbild. Und überhaupt die ganze freie Software-Szene ist natürlich auch ein großes Vorbild für mich jetzt. Also Vorbild in dem Sinne, dass ich sage, das ist eine Szene, in der viele Leute sich mit dem Thema auseinandersetzen. Aber ich meine, du hast mehr mit Programmierern jetzt direkt zu tun. Aber es passiert mir so oft, dass ich mit Leuten spreche, die in dem Geschäft sind, die also wirklich Programmentwicklung machen und so weiter, die nicht wissen, was Open Source ist. Da denke ich dann auch immer, das kann doch jetzt nicht euer Ernst sein. Oder das ist ja nun schon noch wesentlich weiterverbreitet eigentlich als Creative Commons und dergleichen. Aber ich will es mal so sagen, es sollte eigentlich nicht zur Kernaufgabe jedes Kreativen gehören, sich mit dem Urheberrecht auseinandersetzen zu müssen. Ich bin jetzt selber Freiberufler und das ist auch noch mal ein entscheidender Unterschied. Diejenigen, die freiberuflich arbeiten, die sollten eigentlich nicht drumherum kommen, können sich mit diesen Dingen zu beschäftigen, weil die ja ständig Verabredungen treffen müssen. Wenn man angestellt ist, hat man im Regelfall über seinen Arbeitsvertrag die meisten Dinge geregelt. Ob zu seinem eigenen Vorteil, das ist noch offen, aber man kann sowieso nichts dran ändern. Also es wird einem jetzt nicht gelingen, vieles ist ja auch tarifvertraglich geregelt, es wird einem jetzt nicht gelingen, als angestellter Journalist bei einem großen Verlag zu sagen, ich will aber eine andere Urheberrechtsregelung, als die, die im Tarifvertrag steht. Das klappt nicht. Das muss aber in dem Sinne tatsächlich auch nicht sein, weil es ja immer vor allen Dingen um eine angemessene und faire Vergütung geht. Und wenn man jetzt ein Gehalt bekommt, dann bemisst sich diese Angemessenheit häufig viel mehr daran, wie viele Stunden muss ich arbeiten, wie hart sind meine Dienste und dergleichen. Und nicht so sehr, welche Rechte trete ich ab an meinen Erzeugnissen. Die gehören dann im Grunde genommen eh dem Verlag. Also nicht jetzt im strengen juristischen Sinn. Das Urheberrecht in Deutschland ist ja tatsächlich nicht abtretbar. Also man kann es nicht abtreten wie das amerikanische Copyright. Aber die Verwertungsrechte kann man halt alle abtreten. Und das ist im Grunde genommen im Alltag in den meisten Fällen fast gleichbedeutend. Vor allen Dingen bei so Leuten wie mir, die eben im Grunde genommen Gebrauchsprosa schreiben. Das ist noch mal was anderes, wenn man jetzt wirklich Künstler ist, wenn man als Schriftsteller ist oder Maler oder Filmemacher.
Naja, vielleicht noch mal zu dieser Netzwelt. Hast du den Eindruck, dass da eine andere Kultur herrscht, sich mit den eigenen Angelegenheiten auseinanderzusetzen? Was so die politische Dimension betrifft als jetzt in anderen Szenen? Oder ist das jetzt auch schon wieder zu weit hergeholt?
Nee, das ist nicht zu weit hergeholt. Das sehe ich ganz klar so. Das hat eben was damit zu tun, denke ich, dass viele, die sowas machen wie Blogs zu schreiben, in Blogs zu schreiben oder auf andere Arten und Weisen zu veröffentlichen, Radiopodcasts zu machen und dergleichen mehr, dass die ja häufig in anderen Zusammenhängen arbeiten. Das sind ja oft Freiberufler. Das sind Leute, die auch ein bisschen unternehmerischer denken. Nicht zwangsläufig, aber ich glaube, der Anteil der Leute ist höher. Und deswegen machen die sich da auch mehr Gedanken darüber. Und wenn es um solche Themen geht, also wenn es um konkrete Urheberrechtsveränderungen geht, haben die ja ganz oft was mit der Digitalisierung zu tun. Das ist ja der Grund, warum da dran so viel gemacht wird am Urheberrecht. Das ist ja der Ursprung, Digitalisierung und Internet. Und dann ist es eigentlich relativ klar, dass diejenigen, die sich jetzt sehr viel auch mit Digitalisierung und Internet inhaltlich beschäftigen, irgendwann aufs Urheberrecht stoßen. Also es wird oft gesagt, dass Urheberrecht sei das Marktordnungsrecht des 21. Jahrhunderts oder manchmal das Öl des 21. Jahrhunderts und dergleichen. Und da ist ja auch was dran. Also dieses ständige Darauf-rum-Reiten, dass wir in einer Gesellschaft leben, die keine Bodenschätze hat und wir von unserer Kreativität leben und so weiter und so fort. Das wird ja häufig nur als Argument genutzt, um eine stärkere Regulierung einzuführen. Aber für diejenigen, die auf eine solche Art arbeiten, wird eben schon deutlich, dass es ganz viel mit ihrem Alltag zu tun hat.
Vielleicht strahlt das ja ab. Also vielleicht ist das ja sozusagen auch nur ein Zeichen der neuen Generation und gar nicht so sehr, dass man sich mit Computern beschäftigt. Vielleicht ist es wirklich diese Netzbewegung, die jetzt sozusagen sich mehr um ihre eigenen Angelegenheiten kümmert, weil sie einfach die Zeit dafür findet, da durch die Kommunikationswege es leichter geworden ist, an News reinzukommen.
Ja, vielleicht ist das so, vielleicht ist das so. Aber da bin ich wieder ein bisschen im Zweifel, muss ich sagen. Denn wenn ich mir anschaue, wie viele Menschen zum Beispiel bei Facebook sind und da durchaus auch aktiv sind, dann nutzen die ja auch diese neuen, in Einführungsstrichen, Kommunikationsmöglichkeiten und sind im Grunde genommen ständig mit Urheberrechtsfragen konfrontiert. Sie merken es nur nicht, weil es sie auch nicht interessiert. Also das ist einfach so in den Alltag übergegangen. Also so was wie Social Networks zu nutzen, hat ja nicht mehr zwangsläufig was damit zu tun, dass man sich für das Internet, die Digitalisierung oder wie auch immer inhaltlich interessiert. Sondern das ist ja eben genau für viele ein völliges Alltagsphänomen geworden, was einerseits gut ist, aber andererseits dann eben auch dazu führt, dass sich Leute mit solchen Fragen gar nicht beschäftigen. So wenig, wie man sich früher mit dem Urheberrecht beschäftigen wollte, wenn man selber nur ins Theater gegangen ist, dann hatte man da halt keinen Interesse dran.
Kommen wir mal so langsam so auf die Kerngeschichte und denke, da ist es vielleicht ganz sinnvoll, auch mal so ein bisschen geschichtlich einzusteigen. Nicht zuletzt deshalb, weil auch man häufig aus Kritiker-Ecke dann auch schnell mal so, wie es ja früher war, gerne hergeleitet bekommt. Ich finde die Diskussion manchmal auch ein bisschen verwirrend, weil wie immer das natürlich immer so ist, jeder sucht sich den Aspekt raus, der ihm jetzt gerade am besten in den Kram passt. Aber es ist ja nun auch nicht so, dass es Urheberrecht schon immer gegeben hätte. Das ist ja irgendwie auch eine Erfindung der moderneren Zeit. Wo kommt es denn her eigentlich?
Ja, also es ist völlig richtig. Es ist ein sehr neues Rechtsgebiet. Es hat verschiedene Ursprünge und die ersten liegen sicherlich im Buchdruck oder auch in, ja vielleicht kann man sogar sagen, noch früher bei denjenigen, die Stiche gemacht haben. Also Dürer zum Beispiel war einer derjenigen, der in Urheberrechtsgeschichten häufig genannt wird, weil er jemand war, dessen Werke eben auch kopiert wurden und der sich eingesetzt hat dafür, dass das aufgehört hat. Und...
Erfolgreich?
Ja, ich glaube erfolgreich oder na ambivalent. Also gegen manche erfolgreich, gegen andere nicht so erfolgreich, wenn ich mich jetzt richtig entzanne. Und richtig bedeutend wurde die Auseinandersetzung mit dem Buchdruck. Und da gab es aber noch lange kein Urheberrecht, sondern da waren es vor allen Dingen die Verleger, die sogenannte Privilegien haben wollten. Das heißt, die wollten, dass nur sie ein bestimmtes Buch veröffentlichen durften, dass das nicht sofort nachgedruckt werden durfte. Und diese Privilegien wurden von den Fürsten vergeben damals. Also wir reden jetzt wirklich so vom Ende des 15. Jahrhunderts und dann im 16. Jahrhundert, dass das wirklich begann und als der Buchdruck eben auch eine neue Bedeutung bekam durch die Reformation und dergleichen. Also da spielt halt vieles zusammen und es gab Bedarf und es sollten Bücher gedruckt werden und da waren eben dann auch die Verleger sehr stark dahinter her, dass eben diese Nachdrucke nicht auf den Markt kamen und zu dem Zeitpunkt war das Problem dann für die eher, dass der jeweilige Fürst eben nur dieses Privileg vergeben wollte und die Fürstentümer waren ja sehr klein. Also man kennt ja das vielleicht noch aus dem Geschichtsunterricht, der Flickenteppich Deutschland, bei dem eben ungefähr 15 Kilometer entfernt schon wieder ein anderer Fürst herrschte und da war es dann eben auch nicht weit her mit diesen Privilegien. Und ja, also eine ziemlich verfahrene Situation, aber was da dran vor allen Dingen wichtig ist, es hatten zuerst die Verleger ein Interesse daran, die Publikation zu schützen. Es ging nicht um die Autoren, denn der, sagen wir mal die Vorstellung des Autors, die wir heute haben, die wiederum ist ja auch sehr stark geprägt aus der Zeit, aus dem Geniegedanken, aus einer viel späteren Zeit, also eher 17. bis 18. Jahrhundert, als der Autor sich sozusagen herausschälte, als derjenige, der in seiner Originalität jetzt dieses Werk geschafft hat. Die früheren Schreiber, die haben sich viel eher noch verstanden als solche, die einfach etwas hinzugefügt haben zu einem, ich will mal sagen, fundos an Wissen und dergleichen. Die hatten noch gar nicht unbedingt diese Vorstellung davon, dass sie das Genie waren, das jetzt etwas Neues schafft und deswegen auch ein Recht haben sollte, darauf kontrollieren zu können, was mit diesem Werk getan wird. Und das erste richtige Urheberrechtsgesetz, wenn man so will, das gab es in England 1710, das war das Statute of Anne. Anne. Anne. Anne Stewart war Königin damals. Anne, genau. Und sie hat damals, also nicht sie, sondern zu der Zeit wurde eben dafür gesorgt, dass es zum ersten Mal Exklusivrechte gab eben auf diesen Druck. Und das Interessante war...
Warte mal kurz. Ich fand diesen Aspekt ganz interessant, dass der Autor existierte so in dem Sinne gar nicht. Das heißt, kann man ja eigentlich auch ganz gut nachvollziehen, wenn ich mir so vorstelle, dass die ersten Leute, die jetzt sagen wir mal überhaupt des Schreibens ermächtigt waren, im Sinne von, dass sie technisch dazu überhaupt, also dass sie über sich überhaupt gesellschaftlich an einer Position befanden und dann eben auch technisch und von ihrem Fokus her sich eben mit diesem Erzeugen von Buchdruck beschäftigt haben, dass das nicht am Anfang auch die Leute waren, die jetzt so gedacht haben, ich schreibe mal ein Buch, sondern dass sie eigentlich erst mal, was weiß ich, fingen an mit der Bibel so. Das ist ja sozusagen die Definition von schon herumliegenden Schriften in Anführungsstrichen oder Erzählungen. Genauso, was weiß ich, hatte man vielleicht so die ganzen Denker, die so in ihren Tonnen da rumlümmelten und so, die dann erst mal interviewt werden mussten. Und dass das dann sozusagen sich erst gewandelt hat, dass eben quasi die Technologie so weit aufgenommen wurde, dass überhaupt erst mal so etwas wie ein Autor entstehen kann.
Ja.
Ja, so ein bisschen das Analog zu diesem, ja, jetzt haben wir irgendwie das Internet so. Und am Anfang haben dann erst mal alle das reingeknallt, was sowieso schon da war. Ich denke da so was wie an Songtexte, ja, die irgendwie von vielen Leuten zusammengetragen wurden und irgendwann ist das eben noch das eigene Schreiben, das eigene Blog, das eigene Schaffen im Netz eben, weil es eben dort möglich ist, hinterhergekommen. War das so ein bisschen so die, ist das so eine Analogie, die man da ziehen kann?
Also ich glaube schon, dass man die ziehen kann. Vor allen Dingen oder es ist vielleicht, vielleicht ist Analogie nicht der richtige Begriff, sondern eher, dass wir eine Entwicklung haben, die sich wieder zu dem hin zurück bewegt, was es schon mal gegeben hat. Nämlich, dass heute die Vorstellung davon, dass man etwas gemeinschaftlich schafft oder schöpft, wieder viel größer geworden ist, als in dieser Zwischenzeit. Dafür ist ja zum Beispiel Software das beste Beispiel. Also Firefox ist urheberrechtlich geschützt. Also es steht unter der GNU Public License, aber das heißt ja, dass es urheberrechtlich geschützt ist. Das heißt, das, was in dieser Lizenz drin steht, muss eben auch oder kann eben auch durchgesetzt werden. Aber was die aktuelle Version von Firefox noch mit der ursprünglichen Version von Firefox zu tun hat, das werden ja nicht so richtig viele Zeilen Programmcode sein. Und in der Zwischenzeit haben Dutzende oder vielleicht Hunderte, ich weiß nicht genau, wie es in dem Projekt ist, Leute daran mitgearbeitet. Also gut, wenn man die ganzen Plugins und Addons und so nimmt, dann sind sicherlich Hunderte von Leuten, die daran mitgearbeitet haben. Also was ist da, wer ist da jetzt der Autor? Das heißt, insofern können sich die Leute, die sich so ein bisschen mit Programmierung und diesem Geschäft auskennen, sicherlich sich vorstellen, was es damit auf sich hat. Aber dieser genialische Einzelautor, der ist eben durch die Literatur entstanden, ja auch durch Selbstverständnis und dieser in Deutschland ja auch, sagen wir mal, aufgekommene Genie-Kult, hatte natürlich was damit zu tun. Das heißt, ein Autor hat sich eben auch selber beschrieben, als derjenige, aus dessen Genie das alles entsprungen ist. Und gerade jemand, also Goethe in Deutschland, als der Autor, Gott im Grunde genommen, hat ja auch sehr stark dazu beigetragen. Sicherlich auch reflektiert. Also auch er war ja jemand, der wusste, dass er ganz stark auf Anderleuts-Schöpfungen aufgebaut hat. Aber natürlich kann man erfolgreicher sein und das wusste er sicherlich besser als jeder andere zu seiner Zeit. Wenn man sich als jemanden porträtiert hat, der eben in der Lage ist, das alles zu synthetisieren oder wie man es auch immer nennen will. Er hätte das sicherlich damals so nicht genannt, sondern es ist diese vor allen Dingen diese Originalitätsgedanke. Also der Autor schafft etwas aus sich heraus, etwas Originelles und das ist ja eben auch der Gedanke des Urheberrechts. Also es geht da immer um das Werk. Das Werk ist das, was geschützt ist. Das ist ein ganz wichtiger Begriff und das sind persönliche geistige Schöpfungen. Und das ist natürlich eine ganz fundamentale Definition, weil man sich fragen muss, was sind denn diese persönlichen geistigen Schöpfungen? Also geistige Schöpfungen, okay, muss man vielleicht nicht so viel dazu sagen, aber dieses persönlich. Es gibt diesen berühmten Satz, der Newton zugeschrieben wird, ich kann weiter sehen als andere vor mir, weil ich auf den Schultern von Riesen stehe. Das bedeutet natürlich, ich kann das schaffen, was ich schaffe, weil vor mir schon ganz viele andere, andere wichtige Dinge geschaffen haben. Und das ist schön mit diesem Satz, weil man praktisch eine Geschichte dieses Satzes entdecken kann. Der ist nicht von Newton, obwohl er dem häufig zugeschrieben wird, sondern hat schon, ich glaube Bernhard von Schatre, also 200 oder ich weiß nicht, wie viele Jahre vorher so oder so ähnlich geäußert. Und der wiederum hat ihn wahrscheinlich in der griechischen Mythologie aufgespürt, in der es dieses Bild schon gab von jemandem, von einem Zwerg, der auf den Schultern eines Riesens steht und deswegen weiter sehen kann. Und damit war schon eben auch wirklich diese Metapher gemeint.
Also man könnte ja auch genauso gut argumentieren. Es gibt überhaupt gar keine originäre Idee, weil eigentlich alles basiert. Also auch das genialische Werk des genialen Autors ist voll mit Ideen und Inspirationen aus anderen Quellen. Adaptiert Motive, die man vielleicht noch aus der Antike kennt, etc. spinnt sie halt wieder neu zusammen. Und da ist man ja genauer an dieser Problematik. Da gibt es auch so einen schönen Begriff dafür. Also was ist sozusagen diese Schöpfungshöhe, die dann quasi definiert, wann dann auch wirklich diese persönliche geistige Neuschöpfung auch erfolgt ist. Was hat denn dieses erste Urheberrecht, dieses Statute of N, in der Hinsicht definiert?
Ja, das hat eben bestimmte Privilegien auch wieder vergeben, nämlich dass Leute, die Autoren bzw. in dem Fall auch die Verleger waren, 14 Jahre lang kontrollieren konnten, dass ihr Buch nicht nachgedruckt wurde. Also was heißt kontrollieren? Sie hatten das alleine gerecht, das zu machen.
Also 14 Jahre nach der Veröffentlichung.
14 Jahre ab Veröffentlichung, genau. Also eine ganz andere Situation als heute, wo es ja so weit gekommen ist, dass wir im Moment 70 Jahre, also dass das Urheberrecht bis 70 Jahre nach dem Tod des Autors gilt. Kann man sich also ungefähr ausrechnen, wenn jemand wie, wer war das, Benjamin Lebert oder jetzt Helene Hegemann, die 16 war oder 17, als sie dieses Buch veröffentlicht hat, wenn die jetzt sagen wir mal so durchschnittlich alt wird, glaube ich Lebenserwartung irgendwie so bei 78 Jahren, so was in der Größenordnung. Also dann gilt das Urheberrecht 130 Jahre, in ihrem Fall. Und damals waren es 14. Das ist schon ein erheblicher Unterschied.
Aber 50 Jahre fast schon.
Habe ich mich jetzt verrechnet. Das ist schon erheblich. Oder Gürtis Wärter. Ich meine, der ist ja auch sehr früh in seinem Leben entstanden.
Und das in einer Zeit, wo man das Gefühl hat, nach zehn Jahren ist schon wieder alles anders.
Ja genau. Nur, ich wollte noch einmal auf diese Frage eingehen, die du eben gestellt hast im Grunde genommen. Nämlich danach, ob man jetzt davon ausgehen kann, dass nicht sowieso alles praktisch auf dem beruht, was vorher schon gemacht wurde. Und dass dieser Begriff der Neuschöpfung oder der Originalität eben damit auch hinfällig geworden ist. Das ist ein Streit, der weiter tobt. Den hat es in dieser Diskussion darüber gegeben, über den Tod des Autors. Die französischen Philosophen haben das in den 60er Jahren. Also da war das eine große Frage, die diskutiert wurde. Und die ist in der Literaturwissenschaft auch im Grunde genommen nicht beantwortet. Das heißt, sie ist überhaupt nicht beantwortet. Aber sie wird eben heute noch diskutiert und heute wieder stärker diskutiert durch diese Entwicklung, die das alles genommen hat. Es wäre nur, denke ich, falsch, jetzt sich das zu einfach zu machen und zu sagen, naja, also jemand musste die Schrift erfunden haben, damit ich überhaupt schreiben kann. Jemand musste jetzt auch noch, sagen wir mal, die Rechtschreibung qualifiziert haben, damit das überhaupt alle lesen und verstehen können. Und das, was ich beschreibe, ein Auto ist ja auch von anderen erfunden worden. Und weil das alles der Fall ist, gibt es im Grunde genommen überhaupt keine Originalität mehr. Da würde man es sich, denke ich, zu einfach machen. Was, glaube ich, jeder auch respektieren kann, der ein Buch liest, einen Film sieht, ein Musikstück hört, von dem er sagt, das ist toll, also das ist spitzenmäßig. Da hat jemand Gedanken, Inspiration und so weiter zusammengefasst auf eine Art und Weise, wie ich sie im Grunde genommen noch nie gehört habe oder gelesen habe. In den meisten Fällen ist das dann nicht der Fall. Also wenn dann sich ein Literaturwissenschaftler damit beschäftigen würde oder ein Musikwissenschaftler oder ein Filmwissenschaftler, dann würde er sagen, ja, ich meine gerade geniale Filme, nehmen wir Quentin Tarantino, der bedient sich ja so dermaßen aus dem Fundus der Filmgeschichte. Da ist es ja sogar so, dass gesagt wird, das kann man im Grunde genommen nur richtig goutieren. Wenn man alle diese Zitate kennt, dann muss man selber der totale Filmfreak sein und einen ganz großen Überblick über die Geschichte des Films haben, um wirklich anerkennen zu können, was er da geleistet hat, weil er im Grunde genommen jede zweite Einstellung von irgendwo anders hat sich inspirieren lassen. Aber wie gesagt, die Frage danach, was Originalität ist und wie groß die Rolle des Autors da ist, das wird schon lange diskutiert. Das ist nicht neu, aber diese Frage wird neu diskutiert. Dadurch, dass eben durch die Digitalisierung und das Internet so etwas wie gemeinschaftliche Schöpfung eine ganz neue Bedeutung bekommen haben. Genial ist ja zum Beispiel dieses Video. Ich weiß jetzt gerade nicht den Titel über das 9th Chord. Dieses Musikvideo, das, ich glaube, ich weiß jetzt gar nicht genau.
9th Chord denn?
Chord, Chord. Also der Akkord. Das ist irgendwie the mother of all funk Chords, der ein Musikstück komponiert hat aus YouTube-Schnipseln, aber aus Dutzenden von YouTube-Schnipseln. Ich komme wie gesagt gerade nicht auf den Namen, ist aber ganz leicht zu finden hinterher. Du hast ja sicherlich Show-Notes, wo man das dann alles nachlesen kann.
So sieht es aus. Die gibt es links ohne Ende.
Ja, und da wird einfach deutlich, wie auch das kombiniert wird. Also es wird sichtbar. Es wird viel sichtbarer als zum Beispiel in einem Werk der Literatur, in der natürlich auch ganz viel Inspiration durchaus auch Zitate, also Zitate im übertragenen Sinn verwendet werden und bei dem, bei denen man das aber normalerweise nicht sofort erkennen kann. Und bei so Werken, bei so Mash-ups und Remixes, da kann man es eben erkennen, weil die im Grunde genommen das genau als Methode verwenden.
Ja, das ist natürlich dann auch so eine grundsätzliche Frage, inwieweit da eine Liberalisierung der allgemeinen Kreativität hilft oder eben dann nicht wirklich ein Schutz auch, wo setzt der Schutz dann sozusagen an?
Ja, und da im Grunde, also das, wir haben ja, das darf ich ja sicherlich sagen, wir haben ja vorher besprochen, dass wir nicht so, dass wir versuchen wollen, nicht so ein Gespräch zu führen, was an jeder, an jedem Satzende irgendwo hin abdriftet. Aber das ist eben auch schwierig bei diesem Thema, weil bei der Frage, die du jetzt stellst, mir natürlich sofort einfällt dazu der ganze ökonomische Aspekt. Das heißt, was die Autoren ja vor allen Dingen auch interessiert, ist, dass sie profitieren, also auch tatsächlich materiell profitieren können von dem, was sie da machen. Damit meine ich jetzt nicht dieses Argument, alle Kreativen wollen nur Geld verdienen mit ihrer Kreativität. Ich denke, dass das, was wir im Netz sehen, ist schlichtweg der Beweis dafür, dass das nicht stimmt. Also, dass es einfach nicht stimmt, dass sie profitieren wollen davon, das sicherlich. Aber dass nicht alleine ein Geldeingang die einzige Form von Profit ist, das hat uns eigentlich das Internet gezeigt. Und das ist auch dieser, wie ich finde, schon fast Paradigmenwechsel, der in der Ökonomie eigentlich stattfinden müsste und ja auch zum Teil stattfindet, wenn es um sowas wie Behavioral Economics geht, also die Ökonomie, die sich eben mit Verhalten beschäftigt, Verhaltensökonomie, bei denen ja auch untersucht wird, warum schreiben zum Beispiel Open-Source-Programmierer Open-Source-Software? Warum machen die das? Sie können normalerweise kein Geld damit verdienen. Es gibt Geschäftsmodelle für Open-Source-Software, das ist klar. In manchen Fällen ist es ja auch so, dass IBM oder Google die Leute dafür bezahlt, einfach zu coden. Am Ende wird es unter einer Open-Source-Lizenz lizensiert. Aber das meiste, was Open-Source passiert, glaube ich zumindest, ist ja immer noch das, was Leute machen, einfach weil sie Spaß dran haben. Und dann eben die anderen Motivationen. Also sie haben Glaubwürdigkeit oder Anerkennung, Credibility in der Gemeinde und so weiter und so fort. Das hat eigentlich gezeigt, dass es andere Arten von Motivationen gibt. Und im Urheberrecht wird aber immer noch argumentiert, dass rein die materielle Reward, also die Belohnung dafür eine Rolle spielt und das eben bezahlt werden muss für alles. Und das ist schwierig geworden, so zu argumentieren. Aber es ist immer noch der Leitgedanke.
Das ist ja auch so ein bisschen so eine Anspruchshaltung, die sich präsentiert. So nach dem Motto, ich bin ein Künstler und ich muss doch auch von meinem Werk leben können. Ich weiß nicht, wenn man jetzt so ein paar hundert Jahre zurückblättert, ich denke nicht, dass das so normal war, dass man als Künstler von seinem Werk leben kann, sondern dass, soweit ich da Geschichtskendnis habe, das ist nicht viel, aber wie sich mir das darstellt, ist so, naja, da gab es halt so die wenigen geförderten Künstler beim Fürst, die haben dann irgendwie da die Musik zelebriert oder vielleicht auch mal das Bild gemalt, aber im Wesentlichen war es eine künstlerfreie Gesellschaft, beziehungsweise die, die dann wirklich künstlerisch irgendwas geschaffen haben, sind da jetzt nicht unbedingt für bezahlt worden.
Ja, aber das wird natürlich gerade von den Befürwortern und da muss ich vielleicht auch mal sagen, es geht jetzt nicht um eine streng urheberrechtskritische Haltung. Also es geht jetzt in erster Linie mir erst mal nicht darum zu sagen, das Urheberrecht muss abgeschafft werden, sondern erst mal zu gucken, was genau passiert denn da und gibt es vielleicht extrem Bestrebungen. Aber das, was du jetzt gerade beschreibst, das ist historisch sicherlich völlig richtig, aber es wurde genau da natürlich als Vorteil und als Errungenschaft des Urheberrechts gesehen, dass die Künstler davon unabhängiger werden konnten. Das heißt, sie waren eben nicht mehr auf diese Almosen, wenn man es mal negativ ausdrücken will, der Fürsten der Mäzene angewiesen, sondern konnten eben selber schöpfen und konnten eben mit ihren Schöpfungen auch Geld verdienen. Das ist aber wohl eben historisch sehr blauäugig, dass man sich jetzt vorstellt, dass es genauso gewesen ist. Ja, auf einmal hatte man das Urheberrecht und die Leute und die Autoren haben jetzt ganz stark davon profitiert oder die Musiker und dergleichen haben ganz stark davon profitiert. Und das meine ich eben auch damit, dass diese ganze Debatte unter einem Mangel an Empirie leidet. Nämlich sich mal genau anzugucken, was hat es denn für Auswirkungen in der Praxis. Und es ist gerade ein neues Buch veröffentlicht worden. Ich muss jetzt tatsächlich mal kurz hier auf meine Notizen schauen. Höfner heißt er. Ich weiß gerade den Vornamen nicht. Ist bei Spiegel online besprochen worden und hat einen enormen Rücklauf da auch ausgelöst. Eckhardt Höfner heißt er genau. Der hat ein Buch geschrieben, Geschichte und Wesen des Urheberrechts. Ein enormes Ding. Zwei Bände, ich weiß nicht, 800 oder 1000 Seiten oder sowas in der Größenordnung. Und der ist Wirtschaftshistoriker. Und der hat untersucht den Buchmarkt in Deutschland und in England im 18. Jahrhundert. Und ich habe ja eben erzählt, im Jahr 1710 ist dieses Statute of N veröffentlicht oder in Kraft getreten, das erste Urheberrechtsgesetz. Und jetzt müsste man ja eigentlich annehmen, dass in England die Buchproduktion explodiert ist und dass es den Autoren allen wunderbar gegangen ist. Das Gegenteil war der Fall. Das komplette Gegenteil war der Fall. In Deutschland, in der es zu der Zeit eben noch kein übergreifendes Urheberrecht gab, das kam viel später, das kam 1837, kann man im Grunde genommen sagen. Also mehr als 100 Jahre später gab es viel mehr Druckerzeugnisse. Das waren Bücher, das waren auch schon Zeitschriften in der Art. Und die Autoren haben zum Teil mehr Geld verdient. Und das widerspricht eben dieser ganzen Vorstellung davon, die ja für viele auch wirklich so auf eine Art einleuchtend erstmal ist, so intuitiv. Ja klar, wenn ich mein Werk schützen kann, kann ich damit Geld verdienen. Und wenn ich es nicht schützen kann, kommt sofort einer und macht einen Raubdruck und ich kann kein Geld damit verdienen. Aber Märkte sind viel komplizierter als das. Und das Bahnbrechende an diesem Buch ist eben, ich habe es, wie gesagt, noch nicht gelesen. Ich kenne nur ein langes Interview mit ihm und auch diese Besprechung. Aber das Bahnbrechende an dem Buch scheint zu sein, er ist auch nicht der Erste, der sowas gemacht hat, aber dass er gezeigt hat an einem ganz konkreten Fall, dass die Auswirkungen des Urheberrechts andere waren, als in der Debatte heutzutage immer als selbstverständlich angenommen wird. Die Erklärungen sind kompliziert, das ist ganz klar. Also wo dran hat es denn dann gelegen, dass dieser Buchmarkt sich so unterschiedlich entwickelt hat. Es ist ein enormer Unterschied gewesen. Es geht nicht darum, dass in Deutschland irgendwie zehn Prozent mehr Bücher erschienen sind, sondern es geht um den Faktor fünf so ungefähr. Also fünf bis zehn mal so viele Bücher sind in Deutschland erschienen als in England oder wie in England. Und die Autoren haben eben zum Teil auch noch besser verdient. Und das lag daran, dass die Verleger in England einfach nicht so einen, also nicht so einem Markt Druck unterworfen waren, nicht so einer Konkurrenz unterworfen waren und sich zum Teil eben auch ausruhen konnten auf ihren Büchern. Und die Bücher waren sehr teuer in England. Das heißt, es ist auch lange ein Privileg der Oberklasse und der oberen Mittelklasse geblieben, Bücher zu lesen. Und die mussten dann natürlich, weil sie so teuer waren, auch was Bestimmtes darstellen. Das heißt, das waren Luxusausgaben. Die waren dann ledergebunden und hatten Goldschnitt und was weiß ich noch alles. Und weil sie dann einfach verkauft wurden zu Preisen, die dem Wochenlohn eines Arbeiters entsprachen. Das heißt, es war unmöglich, dass die Leute sich das, also dass das dann eben Leute mit geringerem Verdienst sich das leisten konnten. Und in Deutschland war das anders. Und in Deutschland war der Markt offenbar auch sehr viel mehr Nachfrage getrieben. Das heißt, die Verleger haben das gemacht, was der Markt gewünscht hat. Und es gab zum Beispiel ganz viele Anleitungen für verschiedene Dinge. Also ich weiß nicht genau, was das war, aber Gärtnern, ein Haus bauen oder sowas in der Art. Und da kann man jetzt sagen, naja gut, das war jetzt auch keine Kunst und das war ja kein richtiger Autor, der dahinter stand, sondern da hat jemand halt Gebrauchs-Dinge geschrieben. Aber das ist natürlich alles Teil dieses Buchmarkts.
Das heißt, ich meine, das ist ja immer so lustig, wenn man so in die Vergangenheit von Deutschland blickt. Da waren das früher irgendwie alles so die dahergelaufenen, im Süden so die hoch entwickelten Römer und die Deutschen waren irgendwie die Tumpen aus dem Wald. Und heute ist es irgendwie so das Land der Dichter und Denker. Kann es sein, dass wir nur durch die Abwesenheit von Urheberrecht dazu geworden sind?
Also Höffner behauptet genau das. Höffner behauptet genau das. Das ist also eine seiner Hauptthesen. Er sagt, Deutschland wurde zum Land der Dichter und Denker, weil in dieser Zeit tatsächlich es kein Urheberrecht gab. Man kann natürlich jetzt nicht argumentieren, weil man es einfach nicht weiß. Also die Wenn-Frage, die ist ja sozusagen historisch illegitim. Man kann jetzt nicht sagen, wenn es in Deutschland das Urheberrecht gegeben hätte, dann hätte sich alles anders entwickelt. Aber es ist nun mal so wie es ist. Und diese irrsinnige Menge an Büchern, die produziert wurde und dieser Markt, der sie entwickelt hat und das einfach Leute sich vorgestellt haben, sie können, also dass es für Menschen in Deutschland selbstverständlich war, Bücher kaufen zu können und lesen zu können, das war natürlich ein erheblicher Vorteil gegenüber dann eben einem Markt wie England.
Na gut, heute kann man jetzt nicht gerade von einem Mangel an Büchern sprechen, obwohl es das Urheberrecht gibt. Insofern, denke ich mal, haben sich da die Bedingungen auch wieder ein bisschen geändert. Aber gab es denn noch weitere wichtige Wege, die das Urheberrecht jetzt genommen hat, nachdem die Briten da mal vorgestoßen sind und sich ihren Berufmarkt versaut haben?
Ja, also weitere wichtige Wege ja. Ich würde gerne auch hier kurz nochmal, weil ich das nicht auswendig kann, aber aus meinen Aufzeichnungen hier zitieren. Das erklärte Ziel dieses Statutes of N war, encouragement of learned men to compose and write useful books. Also im Grunde genommen gebildete Männer dazu zu ermutigen, nützliche Bücher zu schreiben. Das stand explizit in diesem Statute of N. Das heißt, da wird auch schon ein Motiv deutlich, dass im Grunde genommen in dieser ganzen Urheberrechtsgeschichte eine ganz große Rolle spielen sollte und eben heute nach Ansicht vieler Kritiker nicht mehr spielt. Das ist also ein Hauptgrund der Kritik auch, dass das Ziel des Urheberrechts eigentlich sein sollte, dazu beizutragen, dass mehr geschaffen wird und dass dieses Ziel verfehlt wird. Ich habe noch eben hier aus der amerikanischen Verfassung, das war im Grunde genommen so das zweite Urheberrechtsgesetz, was festgeschrieben wurde, auch noch dieses Zitat, das nämlich die Verfassung, den Kongress der Vereinigten Staaten dazu in die Lage versetzt. To promote the progress of science and useful arts by securing for limited times to authors and inventors the exclusive right to their respective writings and discoveries. Das ist jetzt auch sehr schöne Gesetzesprosa, noch dazu ein paar hundert Jahre alt. Also im Grunde genommen hat der Kongress das Recht, Gesetze zu erlassen, die den Fortschritt von Wissenschaft und Kunst fördert oder fördern, indem sie den Autoren für eine begrenzte Zeit, ganz wichtiger Punkt hier, für eine begrenzte Zeit die Rechte eben an ihren Schriften und Entdeckungen zu übertragen. Also alleinige Rechte heißt das, womit wir bei diesem Begriff des Monopols sind. Denn das Urheberrecht ist im ökonomischen Sinn ein Monopolrecht. Das heißt, der Staat vergibt Monopole. Durch das Urheberrecht habe ich das Monopol auf mein Werk. Wenn es sich denn um ein Werk handelt, dann genieße ich das Urheberrecht und dann kann ich bestimmen darüber, was damit passiert. Weil du fragtest, was jetzt noch so eine große Rolle gespielt hat. Und das spielt insofern eine große Rolle, dass es in den aktuellen Auseinandersetzungen eben oft darum geht, wenn wieder mal die Urheberrechtsdauer verlängert wird. Wir hatten die schöne Situation, also jetzt in Ironiezeichen die schöne Situation kürzlich, als es um die Verlängerung der Schutzfristen für Musikaufnahmen ging innerhalb der Europäischen Union, dass sich im Grunde genommen alle wichtigen Akademiker Europas dagegen ausgesprochen haben, dass diese Schutzfristen nachträglich verlängert werden. Unter anderem deshalb, weil es natürlich schlicht undenkbar ist, dass nachträglich Kreativität angespornt wird, dadurch, dass Urheberrechtsschutzfristen verlängert werden. Es gibt diese schöne Anekdote auch aus dem Kampf von Lawrence Lessig gegen das, gegen den Sunny Bono Copyright Act in den USA, auch bekannt als Mickey Mouse Protection Act. Also diese Auseinandersetzung in den USA ist ja deshalb auch so berühmt geworden, weil es im Grunde genommen da abzulesen ist. Jedes Mal, wenn Mickey Mouse in die Public Domain übergehen könnte, also gemeinfrei werden könnte, weil das Urheberrecht ausläuft, setzt sich Disney mit all seiner Lobbying macht dafür ein, dass die Urheberrechtsdauer verlängert wird und schafft es eigentlich auch immer. Und dagegen hat Eric Eldred geklagt, der, muss ich mal überlegen, ich glaube, der hatte eine Art Archiv, ein Onlinearchiv für Schriften, die eben in der Public Domain waren. Und da sollten viele eben wieder, weil es ja eine nachträgliche Verlängerung der Schutzfristen war, wären viele wieder in diese Schutzfrist hineingekommen, wären also wirklich wieder urheberrechtlich geschützt worden. Und der hat geklagt und Lawrence Lessig hat ihn damals vertreten vor dem Supreme Court in den USA. Und jetzt gibt es in den USA dieses Institut der sogenannten Amicus Briefs. Das heißt, das sind Schriften, die Freunde, die der Anklage oder Freunde der Verteidigung veröffentlichen können, um Stellung zu beziehen dazu. Und da gab es einen Amicus Brief von 17, glaube ich, amerikanischen Ökonomen. Das ist auch sehr spannend. Ökonomen, also nicht Rechtswissenschaftler. Von Rechtswissenschaftlern gab es sowas natürlich auch. Zahlreiche der prominentesten amerikanischen Urheberrechtler haben Partei ergriffen für diesen Fall von Eric Eldred. Aber es gab eben auch diese Ökonomen. Und einer dieser Ökonomen war Milton Friedman, also auch kein ganz unbekannter Nobelpreisträger und als wirklich Marktliberaler bekannt. Und der hat gesagt, er wird diesen Amicusbrief nur dann unterschreiben, wenn das Wort No-Brainer darin vorkommt. Also auf Deutsch gesagt, wenn da drin steht, es muss selbst dem hinterletzten Schwachmaten klar sein, dass es nicht sein kann, dass man durch eine nachträgliche Urheberrechtsverlängerung Kreativität anspornt. Aber der Supreme Court hat anders entschieden. Er musste auch tatsächlich nicht über diese Auswirkungen entscheiden, das war das Problem da dran, sondern er musste darüber entscheiden, ob der Kongress das Recht hat, diese Urheberrechtsdauer wieder zu verlängern. Und das Argument war, eine ständige Verlängerung ist eben dann irgendwann nicht mehr vor limited times, wie es in der Verfassung steht. Und ein berühmt gewordener Satz, eines der Befürworter dieser Verlängerung, war eben limited times is eternity minus one. Also eine begrenzte Zeit ist auch die Unendlichkeit minus ein Jahr. Das heißt, da können wir uns also noch auf einiges gefasst machen, was die Zukunft der Urheberrechts-Schutzdauer-Verlängerung angeht.
Dieser Einspruch von diesem Eric Eldred zu dieser ganzen Copyright-Verlängerung war der Vorstoß, ja, maletwegen kann man das ja verlängern, aber dann muss man dann auch dafür zahlen.
Nein, das entstand dann eher daraus, also in den USA und in England war es ja so, haben wir kurz schon angedeutet, es gab diese Urheberrechtsdauer von 14 Jahren. Im Statute of N war festgelegt, wenn der Autor nach diesen 14 Jahren noch lebt, konnte der das Urheberrecht noch mal um 14 Jahre verlängern lassen, praktisch. Also diese Schutzdauer. In den USA waren es, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, auch 14 Jahre zu beginnen und auch da konnte man nach 14 Jahren das eben verdoppeln lassen, aber auf Antrag. Also da ist es ganz klar. In England weiß ich es nicht mehr so genau. Das automatisch passiert in den USA eben nur auf Antrag. Das heißt, man musste erstens sein Urheberrecht registrieren. Das heißt, man musste sagen, dieses Werk soll urheberrechtlich geschützt sein. Und wenn dann die 14 Jahre abgelaufen waren, musste man auch noch mal aktiv hingehen und sagen, ich will es jetzt noch mal verlängern.
Auch dafür zahlen?
Ja, man musste dafür zahlen. Das war aber wohl tatsächlich, ja, ist eine gute Frage. Man musste dafür zahlen und es wurde dann später eben auch, das waren keine hohen Beträge, aber man musste sich eben schon darum kümmern.
Also mehr eine Bearbeitungsgebühr.
Eine Bearbeitungsgebühr, genau. Das ging jetzt nicht darum, dass irgendwie damit Großgeld eingenommen werden sollte. Aber das war ein wichtiges Argument dafür zu sagen, man muss diese Registrierungspflicht abschaffen, die zum Beispiel in Deutschland nie existiert hat, sondern in Deutschland war schon im ersten Urheberrechtsgesetz festgelegt, dass das Urheberrecht automatisch entsteht. Und das war praktisch auch der Beginn dieser unterschiedlichen Urheberrechtstradition. Ich habe ja schon mal kurz darauf hingewiesen, Urheberrecht und Copyright sind schon sehr unterschiedlich oder sehr verschieden in dem Sinne, dass in Deutschland oder in Kontinentaleuropa immer von diesen Autorengedanken ausgedacht wurde. Das heißt, es gibt ein metaphysisches Band zwischen Autor und Werk, das jetzt nicht durch weltliche Dinge durchtrennt werden kann. Also so haben berühmte deutsche Philosophen genau auch zu dieser Frage des Büchernachdrucks und so weiter argumentiert. Fichte, Hegel, Kant, die haben alle tatsächlich über dieses Thema Urheberrecht und Schutz geschrieben. Und das sind ja nun nicht die kleinsten Geister. Und die haben argumentiert, dass es eine eben diese Art naturrechtliche, also eine Art naturrechtliches Urheberrecht gibt. Das heißt, es ist so, dass der Autor automatisch diesen, dieses Band zwischen sich und seinem Werk hat und dass dementsprechend dann eben auch Verwertungsrechte abgetreten werden können, aber nicht das Urheberrecht selber. Jetzt kann man fragen, was soll das dann für einen Unterschied machen? Es gibt es in Kontinentaleuropa eben weiter heute noch mit dem sogenannten Urheberpersönlichkeitsrecht. Das heißt, man kann sein Urheberrecht nicht abtreten. Und wenn jetzt etwa jemand meine Musik für eine Werbung für Panzer oder so verwendet, kann ich immer noch hingehen heutzutage in Deutschland und sagen, obwohl ich mal meine Rechte exklusiv an irgendeinen Musikverlag lizenziert habe, das heißt, ich habe die Verwertungsrechte alle abgetreten, darf diese Firma das nicht in der Panzerwerbung verwenden, weil das meiner Intention, die ich mit diesem Werk verfolgt habe, völlig widerspricht und so weiter und so fort. Das ist in den USA nicht möglich, das heißt, das wird eben Urheberpersönlichkeitsrecht genannt oder droit d'auteur Rechte des Autors oder Moral Rights, also moralische Rechte, wobei das dann eben keine richtige Übersetzung wäre.
Da werden USA einige Musiker, die sich darüber aufgeregt haben, dass die Republikanische Partei ihre Songs dann auf Parteitagen gespielt hat, etc.
Genau. Die können dann mit Öffentlichkeit agieren und können sagen, also Leute, das ist ja nun wirklich das Allerletzte, was wir damit bezweckt haben. Und wenn sie berühmt genug sind, dann ist es eben auch ein Eigentor für diejenigen, die Musik verwendet haben. Aber rechtlich haben sie keine Möglichkeit. Das heißt, sie können ihr Copyright wirklich vollständig abtreten. Und das geht eben in Kontinentaleuropa nicht. Und das hat eben mit dieser Urheberrechtsgesetzgebung zu tun. Aber wir waren ja noch bei diesen, bei diesen erstens bei der Dauer, bei der Schutzdauer und zweitens, ob man das registrieren musste. Und Deutschland hat sich dann zum Vorreiter tatsächlich gemacht in der Urheberrechtsentwicklung im negativen Sinne. Also sage ich jetzt wirklich aus meiner Einschätzung im negativen Sinne, dass die da drauf gedrängt haben, dass die Schutzdauern sich stark verlängert haben. Und da ist es dazu gekommen, dass 1965 in der großen Urheberrechtsreform in Deutschland festgelegt wurde, dass die Schutzdauer 70 Jahre nach dem Tod des Autors gilt. Da war die in den USA noch kürzer und in allen anderen Ländern eigentlich auch. Und dann ist diese Dynamik entstanden, die heute eben auch von vielen kritisiert wird, dass Urheberrecht ein sehr internationales Rechtsgebiet ist.
Wie war es denn vorher? Vor 65?
Vorher waren es, glaube ich, 30 Jahre nach dem Tod des Autors.
Was war schon immer, seitdem es Urheberrecht in Deutschland gibt, sozusagen definiert mit nach dem Tod?
Ja, also viel länger schon. Viel länger schon als eben in den anderen Ländern.
Und was war da die Argumentation? Ich meine, warum überhaupt der Tod des Autors?
Also der Tod des Autors liegt nahe bei diesen Gedanken der Urheberpersönlichkeitsrechte. Das musste natürlich so lange existieren, wie der Autor lebt. Sonst hätte es ja sein können, dass man schon zu seinen Lebzeiten, also wenn die Schutzfrist abläuft, muss man sicherlich auch noch mal erklären, wenn die Schutzfrist abläuft, ist das Werk nicht mehr urheberrechtlich geschützt. Auch nicht in Deutschland, nicht in den USA, nirgends. Das heißt, diese Rechte verfallen vollständig. Auch nicht ein Teil davon greift noch irgendwie, sondern es ist einfach gemeinfrei oder eben in der Public Domain. Das sind die Begriffe, die dafür verwendet werden. Also Public Domain haben sicherlich viel mehr Leute gehört als gemeinfrei, was daran liegt, dass diese amerikanische Diskussion so viel mehr Öffentlichkeit bekommt. Und dann liegt es natürlich nahe, dass, wenn man davon ausgeht, dass es dieses metaphysische Band zwischen Autor und Werk gibt, dass das auch zu Lebzeiten des Autors eben nicht durchtrennt werden kann. Warum die 30 Jahre muss sich passen, weiß ich jetzt gerade nicht, wie damals argumentiert wurde in der Gesetzgebung. Ob es zum Beispiel einfach schon was damit zu tun hatte, dass gesagt wurde, ja, es muss eben auch dafür gesorgt werden, dass der Autor dann auch ein Eigentumsrecht hat, das über sein Leben hinausgeht.
Oder vielleicht, dass die einfach nicht umgebracht werden, damit Leute irgendwie aus der Gemeinfreiheit da...
Das wäre mal eine spannende Frage, das zu untersuchen.
Ich dachte auch nicht mal, das wäre so das Ding.
Ob die Verleger sonst ihre Autoren abgemurkst hätten, wenn sie praktisch das erste erfolgreiche Buch geschrieben haben, damit sie das dann relativ bald... Aber die Verleger hätten ja kein Interesse daran tatsächlich. Also, die hätten ja... Das ist ja wieder... Also, das ist wirklich eine interessante Frage, weil man daran zeigen kann, dass die Verleger ja selber gar kein Interesse daran hatten, sondern die Autoren haben ja die Verwertungsrechte abgetreten an die Verleger. Und die galten dann natürlich genauso lange wie die Urheberrechte. Das heißt, die Verleger hatten natürlich sehr viel von dieser langen Urheberrechtsdauer. Also, die hätten jetzt kein Interesse daran gehabt, ihren Autor abzumurksen. Die Öffentlichkeit hätte ihn praktisch abmurksen müssen, damit es schneller in Gemeinfreiheit wird. Und das ist halt schlecht denkbar. Also, dass da so eine Bewegung entstanden hätte.
Aber das Verlage sich gegen Sterbehilfe einsetzen, ist wahrscheinlich nur ein Gerücht.
Aber das ist ein sehr interessanter Gedanke. Nicht tot des Autors, sondern tot dem Autor. Damit die Werke schneller gemeinfrei werden. Gut, also jedenfalls, wir waren bei den Schutzfristen und ob das Geld kostet und dann wurde eben nachher damit argumentiert, es darf eben nicht sein, dass der Autor überhaupt irgendein Aufwand hat, sein Recht registrieren zu lassen. In Deutschland war das eben nie so, seit es Urheberrecht gab. Aber in den anderen Ländern war es so, in den USA vor allen Dingen. Und dann wird immer mit dieser Harmonisierung des Urheberrechts argumentiert. Dass gesagt wird, wir müssen also in allen Rechtsgebieten der Welt, in allen Rechtsordnungen der Welt müssen wir das harmonisieren und müssen die gleichen Voraussetzungen schaffen. Und deswegen wurde auch in den USA sehr, sehr spät, in den 80er Jahren oder so des 20. Jahrhunderts, also es ist noch nicht lange her, wurde diese Registrierungspflicht abgeschafft. Und das ist ein Problem. Das ist deshalb ein Problem. Das haben wir an dieser Diskussion über Google Books gesehen, dass es sehr, sehr viele sogenannte verwaiste Werke gibt. Das sind Bücher, Musik, Filme, die urheberrechtlich noch geschützt sind. Also man weiß, dass dieses Buch zum Beispiel 1950 das erste Mal rausgekommen ist. Es kann also, selbst wenn der Autor in dem Jahr gestorben ist, nicht sein, dass das schon gemeinfrei ist, denn dann 70 Jahre wäre ja erst 2020. Aber man kann den Autor nicht mehr finden. Und weil man den Autor nicht mehr finden kann, kann man ihn nicht mehr im Erlaubnis fragen, ob man dieses Buch verwerten darf. Das heißt, dieses Buch ist praktisch nicht verwertbar. Das darf zwar noch in der Bibliothek stehen, aber ich darf das nicht neu auflegen. Ich darf es nicht oder ich darf eine neue Auflage nicht verkaufen. Ich darf auch im Grunde genommen kein Theaterstück draus machen oder sowas in der Art oder das verfilmen. Und das ist zu einem großen Problem geworden. Und deswegen treten eben viele ein dafür, diese Registrierungspflicht wieder einzuführen, die nämlich damals auch zum Teil mit der Begründung abgeschafft wurde, die Transaktionskosten sind zu hoch. Transaktionskosten heißt, ich muss eben relativ viel Aufwand treiben dafür, dass ich das registrieren kann in dem Fall. Und das steht in keinem Verhältnis zu dem Gewinn, den ich davon habe. Also ich müsste zum Beispiel jeden Block-Eintrag anmelden, dass der urheberrechtlich geschützt ist.
Das wäre unmöglich.
Ja, das wäre eben heute nicht mehr unmöglich. Argumentiert zum Beispiel auch jemand wie Lawrence Lessig, der sagt, nein, das lässt sich alles automatisieren heute. Und die Gebühren, die könnten verschwindend gering sein. Also man könnte auch eine Pauschalgebühr dafür verlangen und so weiter. Und dann könnte man das eben tatsächlich mit so was wie APs regeln. Und der Vorteil wäre, also man würde jetzt erst mal denken, oh, das ist ja furchtbar, ich muss jetzt alles registrieren lassen. Aber es gäbe einen ganz, ganz eindeutigen Vorteil davon, nämlich, dass nur noch die Werke, also urheberrechtlich geschützt sind, die registriert werden, bei denen also überhaupt eine Verwertungsabsicht existiert. Und wenn jetzt die Urheberrechtsschutzfristen kürzer wären, dann wäre es natürlich auch interessant, wenn man so arbeiten könnte, dass nochmal diese Frist verlängert würde, aber nur bei erneuter Registrierung. Das heißt, wenn jemand ein Buch schreibt, ein Musikstück produziert, bei Software ist es wieder sehr deutlich. Wenn jemand eine Software schreibt, und die hat jetzt 14 Jahre Schutz, nehmen wir mal diesen ursprünglichen Schutz, der mal vor 300 Jahren vergeben wurde.
Was du für Software auch wirklich schon Generationen umfasst. Und nach 14 Jahren gilt Software eigentlich wirklich als uralt.
Deswegen ist es ja so deutlich bei diesem Beispiel Software, nach 14 Jahren hätte niemand mehr Interesse dran, noch mal den Aufwand zu treiben, selbst wenn es so gering wie der ist, das registrieren zu lassen. Und das würde bedeuten, jetzt kann damit gemacht werden, was man will. Und gut, jetzt sagst du selber, bei Software ist es auch wirklich uninteressant, das noch zu verwerten. Die Frage ist, ob das bei...
Das sage ich nicht. Ich meine, es gibt ja auch gute Gegenbeispiele. Was weiß ich, Unix ist 30 Jahre alt und ist immer noch... Die Frage ist halt nur, ich rede ja eher von so einem Produkt, an dem auch gar nichts mehr getan wurde. So wird die so alte Software, die so rumliegt, Firmen, die schon lange out of business sind.
Ja, und gut, bei Büchern würden jetzt viele sagen, aber die Schutzfrist ist viel zu kurz. Aber auch da sage ich, also ich habe ja, ich habe 2003 habe ich ein Buch veröffentlicht, das heißt Schreiben fürs Web. Das ist so ein Sachbuch, da geht es, das ist für Journalisten, da geht es darum, was muss man beachten, wenn man auf Webseiten veröffentlicht, dass man Zwischenüberschriften verwendet, lauter so ein Zeug. Und ich meine, erstens ist das Ding sowieso in der Auflage, keine Ahnung, von 1500 Stück erschienen, die wahrscheinlich bis heute nicht verkauft ist. Ich weiß es nicht, das ist also schon eher so ein Ding, was sich Bibliotheken dann kaufen und ins Regal stellen. Und nach 14 Jahren habe ich null Interesse daran, dass dann noch mal der Urheberrechtsschutz verlängert würde. Also im Jahre 2017 dann eben. Hat das nur noch historisches Interesse. Und dann kann man aber natürlich wieder argumentieren, ja, aber warum denn überhaupt dann? Also wenn du jetzt sagst, das ist doch gar nicht interessant. Es gibt viele Dinge, gerade in dieser Zeit, in der es um Mash-ups und dergleichen geht. Oder gerade bei Film und Musik ist das interessant. Bei denen, an dem Original jemand kein besonderes Verwertungsinteresse mehr hat, aber jemand anderes, was tolles draus machen könnte. Und die Rechteklärung ist aber so aufwendig, also es liegt noch nicht mal unbedingt immer nur daran, dass die ursprünglichen Rechteinhaber so viel Geld wollen für ihr Sample, sondern es ist erstmal schon schwierig, die zu finden. Es gibt spezialisierte Anwaltskanzleien, in den USA noch viel dramatischer als in Deutschland, aber in Deutschland auch ganz klar. Oder die Öffentlich-Rechtlichen, die haben ganze Abteilungen mit Heerscharen von Juristen, die nennen sich Honorare und Lizenzen diese Abteilungen, in denen es nicht nur darum geht, wie werden die Verträge mit den eigenen Mitarbeitern gemacht, sondern auch um die sogenannte Rechteklärung für Fernsehfilme. Also die recherchieren zum Teil monatelang, bis die sagen können, wir haben jetzt wirklich den letzten Inhaltsschnipsel für diesen Beitrag geklärt und können den deshalb verwenden. Und da sind schon Sachen dabei, kann man wirklich mit gutem Recht argumentieren, wenn es diese Registrierung gebe, bei denen eben klar ist, es gibt ein Rechteinhaber, es gibt aber kein Urheberrecht mehr, das ist gemeinfrei und so weiter. Und wir können das jetzt einfach verwenden. Also da würde sich auch nichts ändern.
Genau, und diese Verlängerung, ich meine, wäre es da nicht auch sinnvoll, wenn man sozusagen verlängern kann, dass es dann sozusagen auch mit Gebühren verbunden ist, die dann exponentiell steigen oder so, dass dann irgendwann so ein natürliches Limit ist.
Na, wenn man sich jetzt überlegt, was im Grunde genommen eine gute Idee wäre, dann, weiß ich nicht, müsste man mal länger drüber nachdenken, wie hoch die Gebühren wirklich sein sollten. Aber das Problem ist ja an solchen Gedanken spielen, dass sie im Grunde genommen ohnehin nur im luftleeren Raum passieren. Denn die Situation ist, dass diese Urheberrechte im Grunde genommen ja auch oft mit diesem viel geschmähten Begriff geistiges Eigentum bezeichnet werden. Das heißt, es ist eine eigentumsähnliche Situation. Und deswegen ist es auch nahezu unmöglich in unserem Rechtssystem, diese Schutzfristen zu verkürzen. Weil das nämlich von vielen, auch sagen wir mal, von kritischen Juristen als aussichtslos betrachtet wird, weil man sagt, das ist ein Eigentumsrecht. Und in Eigentumsrechte wird nicht eingegriffen in unserer Gesellschaftsordnung. Also jetzt jemanden, der schon ein Recht hat, ein Verwertungsrecht bis 70 Jahre nach dem Tod des Autos, dem zu sagen, du hast jetzt nur noch 14 Jahre oder du hast jetzt nur noch, bis du tot bist, das wird nicht gelingen. Also das wäre so, wie zu sagen, du hast jetzt... Also ich meine, das Problem ist eben, dass dieser Vergleich hinkt zwischen den materiellen und den immateriellen Gütern, also zwischen den anfassbaren und den nicht anfassbaren Gütern. Der hinkt aber, er hinkt insofern nicht. Dass es eben von vielen als vergleichbar eingeschätzt wird, damit zu sagen, du hast jetzt zwar ein Haus gebaut, aber keine Ahnung, 30 Jahre nach deinem Tod geht das ins gemeine Eigentum über. Das ist einfach in unserer Gesellschaftsordnung undenkbar geworden. Und das wird ja eben auch von den sogenannten Urheberrechtsextremisten, also die so genannt werden, weil sie sich für eine ständige Verstärkung der Urheberrechte einsetzen, nicht unbedingt zugunsten der Autoren, wird das ja immer in Anschlag gebracht, dass das Eigentumsrechte sind und dass die natürlich unter der Eigentumsgarantie stehen und dass die praktisch unantastbar ist.
Ist das irgendwie jetzt ein unumstrittener Fakt, dass das unter Eigentum abgelegt wird? Weil ich meine, so Eigentum...
Also man muss schon in Deutschland sagen, dass es tatsächlich ziemlich unumstritten ist, dass das eben ein eigentumsähnliches Recht auf jeden Fall in dem Fall ist. Was umstritten ist, ist, was das für Konsequenzen hat. Also auch Eigentum ist ja nicht unbeschränkt. Das ist ja immer diese Debatte über die Grundgesetzartikel, also Eigentum ist zwar garantiert, aber es kommt eben auch mit gewissen Verpflichtungen. Also das...
Grundsteuerzahlen zum Beispiel. Naja, und wenn die Autobahn gebaut werden soll, dann wird auch schnell mal enteignet.
Ja, schnell mal eben nicht. Das sind sehr aufwendige Prozesse. Aber es kann auch getan werden. Genau, aber natürlich dann in einem ganz konkreten Einzelfall, in dem argumentiert wird, dass das öffentliche Interesse überwiegt. Und wir hätten es ja bei dem Urheberrecht eben nicht mit einem konkreten Einzelfall zu tun. Also man könnte jetzt sagen, wir müssen jetzt zum Beispiel Thomas Mann enteignen, damit die Sachen endlich ins Gemeineigentum übergehen. Aber darum geht es ja nicht. Sondern es geht eher um eine generelle Gesetzesänderung und zu sagen, jetzt für alle Urheber wird diese Eigentumsgarantie, die jetzt eben bis 70 Jahre nach dem Tod reicht, wird die eben verkürzt. Und das ist, ja, also das ist nahezu aussichtslos, dass das passiert.
Aber wozu verpflichtet denn das? Ich meine, das ist ja Eigentum, was nicht verpflichtet.
Nein, das ist es nicht. Und da ist eben auch ein Ansatzpunkt, um zu sagen, also man muss schon sehen, dass hier nicht einfach damit gemacht werden kann, was man möchte. Also etwa Sachen unter Verschluss halten. Es gibt auch bestimmte Regeln, etwa wenn ein Buch nicht mehr neu aufgelegt wird. Eine Auflage ist vergriffen und das wird nicht mehr neu aufgelegt. Und der Verlag hat jetzt auch kein Interesse daran, das neu aufzulegen. Dann kann der Urheber zum Beispiel auch, ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht, ob er das beantragen muss oder ob das automatisch passiert. Aber man kann dann sein Urheberrecht quasi zurückfordern daran. Beziehungsweise sein Urheberrecht eben nicht. Das hat man eigentlich abgetreten. Aber seine Verwertungsrechte kann man daran zurückfordern und kann sagen, also wenn ihr das jetzt nicht verwertet, dann müsst ihr mir zumindest die Gelegenheit geben, das zu tun. Was dann zum Beispiel dazu führen könnte, dass in Zukunft mehr Leute, die das wahrnehmen, ihre Sachen im Internet veröffentlichen könnten. Also ich finde es zum Beispiel, es gibt ja konkrete Beispiele. Das hört sich immer alles so an, als würde das nicht passieren. Aber das stimmt ja nicht. Ich habe lange nach einem Buch gesucht, über übers Schreiben. Die von E. A. Rauter. Ich habe jetzt den Namen, den Titel des Buches gerade vergessen. Über die neue Macht der Sprache, glaube ich, ist der Untertitel. Und dieses Buch wird in ganz vielen Schreibschulen empfohlen. Das heißt, in vielen journalistischen Seminaren, auch in Seminaren, in denen es um kreatives Schreiben geht und so weiter. Es ist ein ganz berühmtes Buch und das ist nicht erhältlich. Das ist nicht aufgelegt. Das wird nicht neu aufgelegt. Und ich weiß nicht, warum zum Beispiel der Autor nichts daran tut.
Also die neue Schule des Schreibens.
Die neue Schule des Schreibens, genau, danke.
Von der Gewalt der Wörter.
Ja, so heißt es. Ist auch ein ganz tolles Buch. Kann ich auch wirklich jedem empfehlen, der schreibt.
Gibt es auf Amazon noch zwei gebrauchte Exemplare.
Genau. Und gibt es woanders auch noch gebrauchte Exemplare. Als ich es damals haben wollte, gab es ein gebrauchtes Exemplar. Also, jetzt noch eine kleine Anekdote dazu. Aber es gab es ein Exemplar, das mehr kostete, als der Neupreis irgendwann mal war. Und ich habe es gekauft dafür, weil ich es unbedingt haben wollte. Es hat sich herausgestellt, es ist also so bizarr, dass mir das passiert, wirklich. Also ich habe gedacht, mich tritt ein Pferd. Ich komme aus dem Urlaub zurück und habe einen Schreiben in der Post von der Staatsanwaltschaft Cottbus. Und ich bin als Zeuge angeschrieben und muss so einen Bogen ausfüllen mit einer Zeugenaussage, weil dieses Buch, das ich damals gekauft habe, eine Fälschung war. Ich habe tatsächlich im Deutschland des 21. Jahrhunderts habe ich einen Raubdruck gekauft, ohne es zu wissen. Ich habe wirklich mit dem Brief in der Hand da gestanden und habe mir die Augen gerieben und gedacht, das kann ja wohl nicht wahr sein. Da hatten tatsächlich die Leute, die das damals verkauft haben, Bücher nachgedruckt. Man stellt sich ja vor, dass es das heute überhaupt nicht mehr gibt. Und es gibt es auch relativ selten. Aber die haben das wirklich in großem Stil gemacht, gewerblich. Und gegen die läuft jetzt ein Verfahren. Und man kann sich sicher sein, dass sie am Ende verurteilt werden.
Also das Buch hattest du aber zu dem Zeitpunkt auch schon erhalten.
Ja klar, ich habe das Buch vor Jahren, das ist 2007 gewesen. Ich habe das gekauft und ich habe mich dann gewundert, weil es Broschur war und ich dachte, ich habe doch sonst auf den Seiten immer nur gebundene Exemplare gesehen, Hardcover. Und ich habe nie so eine Broschur gesehen davon, aber egal. Ich wollte ja nur das Buch, mich hat ja nur der Inhalt interessiert. Und dann bin ich also dieser Zeugenaussage gefragt worden, ob mir denn sofort aufgefallen sei, dass es sich um eine Fälschung handelt. Und ich konnte gar nicht ausfüllen, dass es mir bis heute nicht aufgefallen ist, dass es sich um eine Fälschung handelt. Nur durch diese Ermittlungen der Staatsanwaltschaft. Ja, ich so als jemand, der sich mit Urheberrecht beschäftigt, das war schon ziemlich bizarr.
Das heißt, man müsste eigentlich mal mit EA Rauta reden?
Man müsste unbedingt mal mit EA Rauta reden und ihm sagen, Junge, verlang deine Verwertungsrechte zurück und stell das Ding zumindest ins Internet. Also ich habe tatsächlich auch schon mal überlegt, ob ich das mache, aber man kommt ja zu nichts. Du kennst das ja.
Ist das ernst? Alexander Rauta?
Weiß ich nicht. Er steht auf seinen Büchern, glaube ich, immer nur mit EA.
Ja, der ist jetzt gestorben. 2006, sagt Wikipedia.
Dann war es für mich eh zu spät. Ich habe ja erst 2007 von dem Buch erfahren.
Jetzt müssen wir 64 Jahre warten.
2006 ist er gestorben. 66. 66 Jahre müssen wir dann warten. Ja, genau so ist es. Also er kann jetzt nicht mehr, aber wobei, nein, das stimmt nicht, seine Rechtsnachfolger, die könnten das machen, aber die muss man dann erst mal finden. Wer sind die Rechtsnachfolger von EA Rauta? Da haben wir ein klassisches Beispiel davon, was dann passiert in so einem Fall. Wenn jetzt noch der Verlagpleite gegangen wäre, was in dem Fall nicht so ist, es ist ein größerer deutscher Verlag, aber wenn jetzt noch der Verlagpleite gegangen wäre, dann hätte man ein richtiges Problem. Dann hat man nämlich, dann hat man keine Verträge mehr, dann weiß man nicht mehr, wie das geregelt war und so weiter und so fort. Und das ist bei Millionen von Werken ist das der Fall. Musik, Film, Bücher und so weiter und so fort.
Ikon-Verlag, den gibt es glaube ich noch. Den gibt es noch, ja. Ja, muss ich erst mal wieder so ein bisschen hier zusammenhaken, was wir eigentlich...
Tim sortiert sich und ich starte den Aufruf hier übers Chaosradio. Also Leute versucht herauszubekommen, wer die Rechtsnachfolger von EA Rauter sind. Wir möchten gerne, dass...
Ist das Buch so toll?
Also es ist auf jeden Fall unglaublich lesenswert und es ist ein Skandal. Also es ist ein großes Wort, aber das ist genau so ein Fall, bei dem ich sage, es ist eigentlich skandalös, dass dieses Buch nicht erhältlich ist. Und es ist ja nur... Ich verstehe auch den Verlag nicht, dass der es nicht neu auflegt. Vielleicht sind es wirklich kleine Auflagen, aber kleine Auflagen sind heute mit so geringen Kosten zu drucken. Ich meine, für die Raubdrucker in Cottbus hat es sich sogar gelohnt, das Ding als Raubdruck zu verkaufen. Und die haben nicht schon ihre Druckmaschinen bezahlt.
Wäre es nicht noch einfacher, einfach zum Verlag zu gehen und zu sagen, hier, kannst du nicht mal On-Demand einschalten?
Ja, im Grunde genommen sollte der Verlag das ja selber eben anbieten. Es ist nur eben seltsam, dass er das nicht tut. Also, wie gesagt, da müsste man sich jetzt mit einem Verlagsmanager unterhalten, wie aufwendig das tatsächlich ist, so ein Buch, ob dann zum Beispiel die Rechte geklärt sind. Also ob mit Router geklärt ist, dass die Bücher in diesem Verfahren angeboten werden dürfen, ob man dafür spezielle Rechte braucht und so weiter. Also online stellen dürfte man es zum Beispiel nicht so einfach, ohne seine Zustimmung.
Vielleicht noch mal so als kleinen geschichtlichen Rückblick, ohne mich zu sehr an der Geschichte festbeißen zu wollen. Aber diese Urheberrechtsverschärfungen in Deutschland sind ja stark umstritten gewesen, was ja auch selber am Anfang schon erwähnt, diese ganzen Körbe, die da so eingeführt wurden und herumgetragen wurden. Was hat denn das im Wesentlichen bewirkt? Also was war da die Motivation? Was wurde tatsächlich getan?
Die Motivation war auch wieder diese sogenannte Harmonisierung des Urheberrechts. Und zwar kam das dadurch zustande, dass 1996 der sogenannte WIPO-Copyright-Treaty verabschiedet wurde. WIPO ist die World Intellectual Property Organization. Das ist eben so ein Dachverband, ist eine Organisation der Vereinten Nationen. Und da geht es eben darum, das Ganze auf, also weltumspannend praktisch zu systematisieren und zu harmonisieren, wie es so heißt.
Oder zu vereinheitlichen, um es klar auszudrücken.
Genau, zu vereinheitlichen. Und weil auch immer eben von so einer Universität dieses Rechts ausgegangen wird, das Urheberrecht, das heißt, das soll eben auch eigentlich in jedem Land das Gleiche sein. Das ist unmöglich. Also keine Ahnung, das wäre nur möglich, wenn es eine Weltregierung gäbe. Und die wird es nicht geben. Aber zumindest wurde eben durch diese Verträge versucht, bei bestimmten Dingen eine Vereinheitlichung zu schaffen. Zum Beispiel bei Schutzfristen. Aber auch bei anderen Dingen. Und das Problem an der Stelle ist, um gleich mit dem Problem anzufangen, dass sowas wie so ein Copyright-Treaty natürlich im Grunde genommen unter Ausschluss der Öffentlichkeit verhandelt wird. Also 1996, als das gemacht wurde, da haben sich wirklich nur die absoluten Freaks mit sowas beschäftigt. Also mit Freaks meine ich jetzt nicht die Urheberrechtsanwälte, sondern Leute, die praktisch von außen kamen, die zum Beispiel Verbraucherschutz oder so was betrieben haben. Die haben damals schon erkannt, oh hier passiert was, was große Probleme bringen wird in Zukunft. Gut, aber dieser Copyright-Treaty wurde verabschiedet. Und dann muss der in die verschiedenen nationalen Gesetzgebungen übernommen werden. Und das passiert in Deutschland ja nur noch übertragen, nämlich über die Europäische Union. Das heißt, in Deutschland, in den USA ist der Copyright-Treaty direkt ins amerikanische Gesetz sozusagen übernommen worden. Der Copyright-Treaty selber ist natürlich nicht für ein Land bindend oder für Bürger eines Landes bindend, sondern für die gelten ja immer nur Landesgesetze. Das heißt, das, was in dem Treaty drin steht, muss nochmal in ein Landesgesetz übernommen werden und dann gilt es. Und das wurde in den USA relativ früh gemacht. Ich weiß jetzt nicht mehr genau, 2001 oder so ist das in Kraft getreten oder früher schon. In Deutschland hat es sehr viel länger gedauert dadurch, dass es erst mal eine EU-Urheberrechtsrichtlinie geben musste. Also die musste erst mal entwickelt werden. Und anschließend wurden aus dieser EU-Urheberrechtsrichtlinie die verschiedenen Landesgesetze entwickelt. Und dann kam es eben in Deutschland dazu, dass im Jahr 2003, wenn ich mich jetzt richtig erinnere, 2003 ist dann dieser sogenannte erste Korb der Urheberrechtsreform veröffentlicht worden. Und was von Anfang an umstritten war, waren solche Dinge wie, wie soll zum Beispiel mit Tauschbörsen umgegangen werden. Da war dann in dem ersten Korb stand dann drin, also in dieser ersten Reform stand drin, das muss man gerade überlegen, wie die Formulierung war, Werke, die unerlaubt vervielfältigt wurden, die dürfen halt nicht im Internet angeboten werden, so sinngemäß und ohne Zustimmung des Rechteinhabers. Und das war aber eine komische Formulierung, ist man dann selber auch drüber gestolpert, weil jetzt im Grunde genommen, es niemandem offensichtlich sein kann, wie ein Werk vervielfältigt worden ist. Also wenn ich jetzt was in einer Tauschbörse zum Beispiel angeboten bekomme, dann kann ich natürlich nicht sagen, wie es in diese Tauschbörse gelangt ist. Es ist ja zum Beispiel erstmal auch, kann ja auch eine Privatkopie sein. Also man darf ja privat kopieren. Also stell dir vor, du nimmst eine CD, rippst die auf deinen Computer und ist das legal. Also es ist ein Kopierschutz drauf, darauf komme ich gleich. Dann ist das halt legal und wenn es jetzt nur verboten ist, diese Kopie dann im Internet zugänglich zu machen, wenn sie unerlaubt entstanden ist, dann wäre das in dem Fall nicht unerlaubt.
Weil die Privatkopie...
Die Privatkopie ist erlaubt und dann darf man das eben auch veröffentlichen. Aber das war eben der erste Versuch, auf diese Tauschbörsen einzugehen. Zu sagen, wir müssen das einschränken, dass in Tauschbörsen all diese Sachen angeboten werden und wir können das nicht verfolgen. Die Rechteinhaber können das nicht verfolgen. Und ein ganz wichtiger anderer Aspekt war das, was ich gerade schon angesprochen habe, nämlich der Kopierschutz. Und zwar steht das im Gesetz als technische Maßnahmen. Das heißt, wirksame technische Maßnahmen sind auch noch mal rechtlich geschützt. Die dürfen nämlich nicht geknackt werden. Das wissen sicherlich auch viele, der Hörer des Chaosradios. Viele andere Leute sind sich darüber nicht im Klaren. Das war diese große Debatte, die es um den Kopierschutz gab und die ein bisschen kleiner geworden ist, weil es in der Musik nicht mehr so eine große Rolle spielt. Also zumindest bei CDs und bei iTunes und so nicht mehr. Es spielt aber, glaube ich, schon noch eine große Rolle. Das wird uns schon noch mal alles auf die Füße fallen. Das ja eine Zeit lang, gerade in Deutschland, Deutschland hat da wirklich versucht, ein Vorreiter, also die Musikindustrie, wollte Deutschland zu einer Art Vorreitermarkt machen. In den USA sind viel weniger CDs mit Kopierschutz verkauft worden. Aber in Deutschland haben sie versucht, ganz viele CDs mit Kopierschutz zu verkaufen. Und wenn ein CD mit Kopierschutz verkauft wurde, dann hatte man auf einmal nicht mehr die Erlaubnis, die zu vervielfältigen, also jetzt auch nicht zu privaten Zwecken. Das heißt, das eine Recht wurde durch das andere ausgehebelt. Und das ist jetzt wirklich so ganz schwierig juristisch, weil es nämlich, also diese Privatkopie ist ein sogenannter Erlaubnistatbestand. Das heißt, das ist was anderes, als ein Recht zu haben. Wenn ich ein Recht habe, dann kann ich das auch durchsetzen. Wenn mir jemand eine Erlaubnis gibt, dann ist das was anderes. Das heißt, ich hatte die Erlaubnis, eine Privatkopie zu machen. Und jetzt gab es aber auf einmal die Situation, dass ich einen Kopierschutz nicht knacken durfte. Das heißt, ich hatte die Erlaubnis nicht mehr. Und weil ich aber kein Recht habe, diese Privatkopie zu machen, das ist übrigens unter Juristen auch wieder umstritten, ob es wirklich dieses Recht gibt oder nicht gibt, aber die meisten sagen, es gibt das Recht nicht, sondern eben nur diese Erlaubnis, konnte ich auch nicht hingehen und sagen, aber ich darf doch eine Privatkopie machen, also muss ich doch auch diesen Kopierschutz umgehen dürfen. Nein, der Kopierschutz durfte nicht umgangen werden. Das ist ja übrigens heute, also das ist ja auf allen Gebieten so, die übliche DVD zum Beispiel ist kopiergeschützt. Die hat dieses Content Scrambling System drauf. Das ist natürlich schon geknackt gewesen, als das Ding auf den Markt kam. Und es knackt auch jeder. Und die Programme dafür sind im Internet zu haben. Aber es ist nicht legal. Das heißt, ich kaufe mir eine DVD, will die aber nicht mit mir rumschleppen, sondern wenn ich im Zug halt das Ding sehen will, dann rippe ich es mir auf den Computer, damit ich nicht in die blöde Situation komme. Ich meine, mein Computer hat keine Ahnung, 320 GB Festwerte, da passt eine Menge Zeug drauf. Also rippe ich mir doch einfach mal fünf solche DVDs in meinen Computer, dann kann ich sie nicht vergessen. Und wenn ich dann im Zug sitze oder im Flieger, dann kann ich es mir halt angucken. Ja, schön und gut, aber ich darf es nicht. Also ich werde jetzt nicht verfolgt dafür in Deutschland, aber die Auswirkungen sind dann, es dürfen keine Programme dafür angeboten werden. Und das würde auch verfolgt. Das heißt, im Grunde genommen...
Aber in den USA schon?
Nein, in den USA auch nicht. Nein, in den USA ist das genauso. Da gibt es diesen ganz berüchtigten Paragraphen, ich glaube 1201 oder so, dieses DMCA, das Digital Millennium Copyright Act. Das war eben diese Umsetzung der WIPO-Copyright-Richtlinie in amerikanisches Recht, dieser DMCA. Und da gibt es eben auch diesen Umgehungsschutz drin, der von Anfang an bekämpft wurde von der Electronic Frontier Foundation, von Wissenschaftlern, die gesagt haben, das kann nicht sein, wir kommen in Teufelsküche. Es gibt auch prominente Fälle, die immer wieder angeführt wurden. Zum Beispiel ist in den USA ganz klar Re-Engineering erlaubt. Das heißt, wenn ich ein Gerät habe und ich möchte wissen, wie das funktioniert, dann darf ich das Ding komplett auseinandernehmen und analysieren und so weiter. Das ist alles erlaubt. Und dann gab es jetzt eine Firma, die hat Garagentoröffner hergestellt. Also jetzt nichts, was einem erst mal so einfällt bei Urheberrechtsverletzungen. Und die haben so einen Garagentoröffner hergestellt. Und ich glaube, eine andere Firma wollte entweder alternative Garagen. Ich glaube, die wollten einfach nur Fernbedienungen dafür anbieten. Wenn die halt so eine Fernbedienung kaputt geht, ist ja häufig so mit exklusiven Produkten. Was weiß ich, wenn du bei Apple einen Adapter kaufst, dann kostet das Ding 30 Euro. Wenn du den Nachbauer kaufst, dann kostet der 15 Euro. Und so war das wohl mit diesen Fernbedienungen auch. Wenn du das Ding, wenn du also drüber fährst über deine Fernbedienung, dann musst du irgendwie für 50 Dollar einen Ersatz kaufen. Die Konkurrenzfirma hat das Ding halt für weniger angeboten. Und dann hat diese erste Firma hat dagegen geklagt, weil sie sagte, nein, unter diesem DMCA ist das nicht erlaubt. Denn Re-Engineering ist zwar erlaubt, aber wir hatten einen Kopierschutz da eingebaut in diese, also eine technische Maßnahme. In dem Fall kein Kopierschutz, sondern eine technische Maßnahme. Und dieses ganze Gesetz ist so wirr und so bizarr. Da steht zum Beispiel drin, wirksame technische Maßnahmen dürfen nicht umgangen werden. Beziehungsweise es dürfen keine Geräte in Umlauf.
Wirksame dürfen nicht umgangen werden, aber in dem Moment, wo sie umgangen werden, sind sie ja nicht mehr wirksam.
Mein Reden, und nicht nur mein Reden, sondern auch viele Juristen, die sich das angeguckt haben, die haben wirklich die Hände über dem Kopf zusammengeschlagen und haben gesagt, oh Himmel, was hat der Gesetzgeber hier getan? Und das ist einer der Fälle, bei denen eben auch viele ganz normale Bürgerinnen und Bürger mitbekommen haben, wie weit das reicht. Du hast dir so eine CD gekauft, hast sie ins Autoradio eingelegt, also in deine Autosteriomanlage und das Ding lief nicht. Warum lief das nicht? Weil dann Kopierschutz drauf war. Das heißt, das hat nicht diesem CDA-Standard entsprochen. Und in Autoradios oder Autosteriomanlagen wurden häufig ziemlich billige CD-Player verbaut. Die konnten dann damit nicht umgehen. Zu Hause lief es häufig noch. Die hatten eine bessere Fehlerkorrektur und so. Im Auto lief es dann nicht mehr. Dann hatten die also sich für, keine Ahnung, 20 Euro eine CD gekauft und das Ding funktionierte einfach nicht. Und dann ging es sogar so weit, dass es ja auch Streit darüber gab. Ich meine, die Verbraucherzentralen haben sich natürlich darum gekümmert, aber dass es dann Streit darum gab, was die Kunden für ein Rückgaberecht hatten. Also wenn zum Beispiel ganz fett auf dieser CD drauf stand, dass da ein Kopierschutz drauf ist, dann haben die Hersteller argumentiert, dann haben die auch kein Rückgaberecht. Und dann denkst du natürlich, also Leute, ihr habt ja sicherlich hier schon oft darüber gesprochen, wie die Musikindustrie sich ihre Kunden zum Feind gemacht hat, aber das war sicherlich auch ein ganz wichtiger Bestandteil. Und Digital Rights Management beruht natürlich zu einem ganz großen Teil da drauf. Also dass wirksame technische Maßnahmen nicht umgangen werden dürfen und dieser Kopierschutz, der spielt ja nicht mehr so eine große Rolle, weil jetzt zum Beispiel bei iTunes auch schon lange der Kopierschutz im Grunde gefallen ist. Das heißt, da kriegt man alle Musik als mp3, was frei weiter kopierbar ist und so weiter.
Als AAC, aber ohne DRM.
Genau, ohne DRM. Aber es gibt ganz viele andere Gebiete, wo das nicht der Fall ist. Nehmen wir mal jetzt Blu-ray, was der Zukunftsmarkt für die Filmwirtschaft werden soll. Da ist ein ganz harter Kopierschutz drauf, der auch bis jetzt in dem Sinne nicht geknackt ist. Dass es kein für Laien einfach bedienbares Programm gibt, mit dem man den umgehen kann. Also er ist zwar sozusagen akademisch geknackt, das heißt es gibt schon einen, glaube ich, Hacker, der praktisch veröffentlicht hat, was dazu, dass man den umgehen kann. Und das funktioniert wohl auch, aber da muss man, wer weiß, was für Handstände machen.
Aber das Netz ist voll mit Blu-ray-Rips, also das ist jetzt nicht selten.
Genau, das ist ja dieser Effekt von, wie heißt es so, BORA, genau, BORA, Break Once Run Anywhere. Das heißt, es muss ja in so einem System nur noch einmal kaputt gemacht werden. Die eine Version, die in der Tauschbörse landet, die reicht ja. Das heißt, ich muss es auch selber gar nicht knacken, sondern es knackt dann der Typ, der es kann und stellt es dann der Welt zur Verfügung. Aber man muss schon sagen, dass das schon natürlich eine starke Einschränkung ist. Also ich glaube, jetzt so, du selber und deine Community, die werden manches davon nur belächeln, ich tue das nicht, denn ich habe keinen Bock nach irgendwelchen Blu-Ray-Rips zu suchen im Netz, wenn ich mir gerade für 30 Euro eine Blu-Ray gekauft habe und einfach das Ding auf meinen Computer übertragen will, damit ich es unterwegs gucken kann. Da will ich mich nicht mehr beschäftigen. Noch dazu, weil es unter Umständen illegal sein könnte, wenn ich mir das Ding runter lade und weil die Rechtsunsicherheit so groß ist und so weiter und so fort. Das heißt, das übt schon einen Druck aus.
Aber willst du dir mit dieser DVD, weil ich meine, hier habe ich ja so eine Software auf meinem Macintosh, die kann man da einfach so kaufen und die rippen mir irgendwie meine DVDs auf die Platte.
Die kann man aber nicht in Deutschland kaufen. Also ich kann die von Deutschland aus kaufen. Ich glaube, bei DVDs ist es in gewisser Weise auch so, dass die Industrie da auch die Hoffnung hat veranlassen und das ist sicherlich auch nicht das schlechteste, was man machen kann. Aber es geht ja darum, dass eben solche Programme, die DVDs rippen, tatsächlich in Deutschland nicht kommerziell angeboten werden dürfen und in den USA auch nicht. Dann kommt wieder dieser umstrittene Punkt rein, was ist jetzt ein wirksamer Kopierschutz? Also in Dänemark oder Schweden war es, wo zum Beispiel auch schon vor Gericht entschieden wurde. Das ist eine Art bahnbrechendes Urteil gewesen, was aber auf andere Länder sich noch nicht übertragen hat. Da wurde gesagt, nein, CSS ist eben genau kein wirksamer Kopierschutz. Es ist kein wirksamer Kopierschutz, weil man ihn mit den leichtesten Systemen oder den leichtesten Angriffen knacken kann. Es ist technisch völlig veraltet und so weiter. Das heißt, er genießt eben auch nicht den Schutz dieses Gesetzes. Aber das ist natürlich immer diese Aushandlungssache, dass man das jetzt praktisch erst im Gericht entscheiden muss, ist es ein wirksamer Kopierschutz oder nicht. Und wenn er wirklich wirksam wäre, müssten ja die Gerichte eigentlich gar nicht bemüht werden, denn dann brauchte man sich darum nicht zu kümmern. Aber das widerspricht der Logik des Computers als Universalmaschine. Es gibt eben diesen wirksamen Kopierschutz nicht. Also es gibt nicht den Kopierschutz, der nicht geknackt werden kann. Und deswegen braucht es diese rechtliche Unterstützung, die von vielen dann eben deshalb kritisiert wird, weil sie alle möglichen Ahnen von Kollateralschäden mit sich bringen.
Tja, in fünf Jahren läuft das Urheberrecht für meinen Kampf ab.
Ja, sehr witzig, oder? Dass das in Deutschland nicht aus anderen Gründen verboten ist, weiter dieses Ding zu vielfältigen und zu veröffentlichen, sondern auf Basis des Urheberrechts. Es gab ja diesen Streit vor kurzem über die Zeitung aus dem Dritten Reich, ein britischer Verleger. Ich habe leider den Namen jetzt vergessen dieser Veröffentlichung, aber der hatte Zeitungen aus der Nazi-Zeit, hatte der wieder veröffentlicht. Und da ging es eben darum, ob er das darf. Und da wurde auch mit Urheberrechtsgründen argumentiert. Und ich meine, er hat aber schließlich vor Gericht gesiegt. Müsste ich dir dann eventuell raussuchen, mir fallen jetzt nicht mehr konkrete Stichworte dazu ein. Und beim Kampf ist es eben so, dass, ich glaube, die bayerische Landesregierung rechtsnachfolger von Adolf Hitler ist und damit darüber bestimmen darf, was damit passiert. Und deswegen wird es nicht gedruckt. Und in fünf Jahren wird es eine große Auseinandersetzung darüber geben, was jetzt passiert. Also ob man jetzt unter anderen, mit anderen Begründungen, meinen Kampf weiter verbieten will. Bis jetzt war es eben einfach.
Ich habe einen Bericht darüber gehört. Wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, haben Sie da wirklich jetzt ein Team herangesetzt, eine annotierte Version davon rauszugeben, weil Sie eingesehen haben, dass wir das dann nicht mehr verboten bekommen. Und dann wollen Sie zumindest kontern mit einer Version, die dann sozusagen auch zwischen den Zeilen Erklärungen rausgibt. Ist doch auch richtig.
Also, ich meine, viele Wissenschaftler, Historiker und dergleichen mehr setzen sich seit Jahrzehnten dafür ein. Und man sieht ja auch, dass in anderen Ländern, ich meine, Deutschland hat eine spezielle Geschichte. Das darf man dabei nicht vergessen. Aber sagen wir mal so, die Situation, die wir im Moment haben, begünstigt ja nur diejenigen, die Schindluder damit treiben wollen. Das, glaube ich, kann man ganz eindeutig sagen. Das ist wie auf vielen anderen Feldern auch, wo Dinge verboten werden. Diejenigen, die wirklich rankommen wollen, weil Adolf immer noch ihr Führer ist, die werden da schon irgendwie rankommen. Die besorgen sich das halt aus den USA oder aus der Tauschbörse und drucken sich's aus und so weiter und so fort. Und diejenigen, bei denen wirklich eine sinnvolle Auseinandersetzung damit stattfinden könnte, die dürfen es halt nicht. Die dürfen eben keine kommentierte Ausgabe anbieten und so weiter und so fort. Und insofern finde ich das völlig richtig, dass das gemacht wird. Und ich finde es ja auch gut, dass dann eben so was angeboten wird. Ich bin jetzt auch nicht der Ansicht, dass man das einfach alles so geschehen lassen soll. Es ist eine Herausforderung, damit umzugehen und mit den Argumenten der Nazis umzugehen und so weiter. Und ich selber wollte den Job nicht machen. Aber das Urheberrecht dazu heranzuziehen, um das zu unterdrücken, das ist einfach eine schlechte Art der Auseinandersetzung.
Jetzt, was muss man denn verstehen, um nachvollziehen zu können, was eigentlich derzeit politisch so in der Diskussion ist? Also, alle scheinen ja irgendwie unzufrieden zu sein mit dem Urheber. Also es gibt einen Konsens darüber, dass alle unzufrieden sind. So, die einen sind unzufrieden, weil es müsste ja alles noch 300 Jahre nach dem Tod gelten. Und überhaupt, warum die Leute noch nicht erschossen worden sind, die schon mal gewagt haben, eine Datei aus dem Internet herunterzuladen. Und dann gibt es dann irgendwie so die andere Fraktion, die der Meinung ist, niemanden darf überhaupt irgendetwas gehören. Und jeder, der auch nur das Worteigentum in den Mund nimmt, muss es auch gleich neben den anderen, der eben gerade erschossen wurde, daneben gelegt werden. Das erscheint mir auch immer extrem unvereinbar. Und ich habe vor allem auch immer so den Eindruck, dass eigentlich keiner so genau weiß, was eigentlich das Problem ist.
Ja, okay, also das Problem, denke ich, ist ja, dass der Eindruck entsteht, dass durch Digitalisierung und Internet... Nein, Moment, nicht der Eindruck entsteht. Was passiert durch Digitalisierung und Internet ist, dass ein Werk, viele Werke, verlustfrei und mit Kosten, die gegen Null tendieren, vervielfältigt werden und vertrieben werden können. Also nicht einfach nur vervielfältigt, also die Digitalisierung alleine reicht zum vervielfältigen aus, aber erst das Internet musste dazukommen, um das Zeug auch noch zu verteilen, also um es auch noch allen Leuten zur Verfügung zu stellen und das auch noch zu enorm niedrigen Kosten. Das kann sich jeder ganz leicht ausmalen, wenn ich mit dem Lkw die Sachen in der Gegend rumfahren muss und Geschäfte brauche, in die ich das reinstelle, kostet das viel Geld und im Internet kostet es eben nicht viel Geld. Und das hat eben zu dieser Situation geführt, dass alle rankommen können und das ist das, was ein Think Tank der amerikanischen Regierung, der sich Sachen mal angenommen hat, schon vor langer Zeit das digitale Dilemma genannt hat. Dass nämlich die Sachen so schnell und so einfach vervielfältigt werden können und damit im Grunde genommen zu unglaublich niedrigen Kosten das Wissen der Welt allen zur Verfügung stehen könnte. Dass aber gleichzeitig die Gefahr droht, dass wenn nur noch ein Exemplar hergestellt werden muss, ein sozusagen Original, wenn man jetzt in dem Sinne mal vom Original sprechen will, ein Original nur noch hergestellt werden muss, um das gesamte Bedürfnis daran zu befriedigen, dass dann auch noch dieses nur noch dieses eine Original bezahlt wird und dass davon sozusagen derjenige, der schafft, nicht leben kann. Und die Diskussion ist am ausgeprägtesten natürlich in der Musikindustrie angekommen, weil Musik offensichtlich das die Werkart ist, die die meisten Leute umtreibt und die praktisch so ein paar Dinge erfüllt. Also Bücher jetzt in Tauschbörsen anzubieten, das fanden alle nicht so interessant. Das wird sicherlich mit dem E-Book nochmal eine ganz andere Diskussion werden, weil man sich ja im Grunde genommen ausdrucken muss und so weiter. Aber Musik, auf einmal wurde die portabel. Auf dem MP3-Player konntest du mit dir rumtragen. Und da war natürlich die Verlockung gigantisch groß, das so anzubieten. Nicht übrigens, um Geld damit zu machen. Also die ersten, die solche Sachen entwickelt haben, die haben das ja nicht getan, um damit davon zu profitieren. Und auf anderen Gebieten kommt es dann aber eben auch so nach und nach an. Also bei Google Books ist ja zum Beispiel der Streit dann viele, viele Jahre später erst entstanden, dadurch, dass auch das Problem sozusagen erst später entstanden ist, dass diese Bücher auf einmal alle eingescannt waren. Ein analoges Buch konnte man eben nicht so einfach vervielfältigen und vertreiben.
Also Google Books hat ja nicht nur urheberrechtsfreie, also gemeinfreie Werke genommen, sondern eigentlich hätten die gerne jedes Buch.
Ja, die hätten gerne jedes Buch, wobei ziemlich klar ist, auch wenn viele behaupten, dass das nicht stimmt. Aber ich glaube tatsächlich selber, dass das nur in Fällen nicht stimmt, in denen was schiefgelaufen ist. Die behaupten, dass Google auch urheberrechtlich geschützte Werke unerlaubt veröffentlicht, meiner Ansicht nach stimmt das nicht. Und wenn das stimmt, dann sind das wirklich Einzelfälle, in denen Fehler gemacht worden ist. Ich meine, die sind ja auch nicht bekloppt dort und die wissen ja, was sie dürfen und was sie nicht dürfen. Der große Streit bei Google Books, der dreht sich in erster Linie nicht um die gemeinfreien Bücher und nicht um die Bücher, bei denen die Urheber bekannt sind und die Rechteverwerter, sondern eben genau um dieses Zwischending, um diese verwaisten Werke, das heißt um Bücher, bei denen die Rechteinhaberschaft nicht geklärt ist und dass die da eben veröffentlicht werden können und dass sich da viele dagegen wehren und so weiter. Und gut, also dieses digitale Dilemma, das eben vermeintlich dazu führt, dass die Leute nicht mehr bezahlt werden können für ihre Kreativität. Und das ist ein guter Ausgangspunkt, um einfach auch mal kurz darzustellen, wie unterschiedlich die verschiedenen, ich will sie gar nicht Branchen nennen, weil das schon immer gleich was mit Kommerzialität zu tun hat, aber die verschiedenen Gebiete, Genres, genau die verschiedenen Gebiete da sind. Im Wissenschaftsbetrieb gibt es ja auch durch den Heidelberger Appell und der dergleichen Unsinn viel Diskussion darüber, über Open Access und ob das erlaubt sein soll. Open Access bedeutet, dass das Bücher auch im Internet eben zur Verfügung gestellt werden können, abrufbar gemacht werden können und es soll gelten, dass Bücher, die mit Unterstützung der öffentlichen Hand finanziert worden sind, Forschungsergebnisse. Keine Bücher, das ist schon falsch. In erster Linie geht es um sogenannte wissenschaftliche Zeitschriften, also um Scientific Journals. Dass diese Veröffentlichungen, die ein Wissenschaftler macht, normalerweise in Scientific Journals, dass die auf jeden Fall auch im Netz kostenlos erhältlich sein sollen, abrufbar sein sollen für andere. Warum? Weil die Öffentlichkeit schon dafür bezahlt hat. Die bezahlt die Universität, die den Wissenschaftler wiederum bezahlt, die bezahlt die Forschungseinrichtungen und so weiter und so fort. Und es kann also nach Ansicht der Befürworter von Open Access nicht sein, dass dann die Öffentlichkeit noch ein zweites oder drittes Mal dafür bezahlen muss. Und in der Tat ist es so, dass jahrelang zum Großteil heute noch Wissenschaftler ihre Rechte exklusiv an große Wissenschaftsverlage abtreten. Das heißt, die dürfen hinterher, also exklusiv heißt, sie dürfen selber diese Sachen nicht mehr veröffentlichen. Zum Beispiel auf ihrer Website, das dürfen sie nicht mehr. Und dann müssen die Bibliotheken wiederum, die Zeitschriften, die veröffentlicht werden, zum Teil zu horrenden Kosten zurückkaufen. Oder auch wenn die Kosten selber nicht horrend sind, so sind sie doch horrend gestiegen. Es gibt die sogenannte, das heißt, das wird in der Fachwelt, also Journal Crisis bezeichnet, dass die Preise für scientific journals in den letzten Jahren also exponentiell gestiegen sind. Und dass viele Bibliotheken der Universitäten und auch der Städte und Gemeinden und so weiter sich einfach diese Veröffentlichung nicht mehr leisten können. Und da zum Beispiel kann man einfach sagen, dieses Problem ist lösbar und wir können auf diese Art von Exklusivrechte der Wissenschaftsverlage verzichten. Jahrhundertelang konnte man das nicht, weil die Wissenschaftsverlage diejenigen war, die diese ganz wichtige Arbeit übernommen haben, dazu beizutragen, wissenschaftliche Veröffentlichungen auszutauschen. Also unter den, in der wissenschaftlichen Community. Das heißt, die wurden gebraucht und die gab es zu Recht. Und die haben ganz, ganz viel geleistet für die Entwicklung unserer aller Gesellschaften. Aber jetzt hat sich eben die Situation grundlegend geändert. Und dann muss sich auch dieses Geschäftsmodell grundlegend ändern. Und der große Vorteil in der Situation ist jetzt, die Wissenschaftler brauchen nicht, um ihre Einnahmen zu bangen. Denn die bekommen nichts für ihre Lizenzen. Das heißt, die treten diese ausschließlich Nutzungsrechte im Normalfall kostenlos ab. Und in Fällen, in denen es um Dissertationen und so weiter geht, ja sogar noch mit Druckkosten zuschüssen. Das heißt, sie zahlen selber dafür, dass sie jemand anderem das ausschließlich Recht geben, das zu veröffentlichen. Also es ist wirklich, es ist so absurd, wie es sich anhört. Es hat natürlich eine Tradition, es gibt ganz rationale Gründe dafür, warum das passiert ist. Aber es kommt zu einem ganz irrationalen Ergebnis. Und deswegen kann man in dem Fall sagen, weil das ist eigentlich ein Problem, bei dem man sagen muss, es tut mir leid für die Wissenschaftsverlage, da ist ein großer Umbruch. Aber die können überleben, sie können überleben, indem sie sich darauf konzentrieren, Dienstleistungen anzubieten. Also zum Beispiel Auffindbarkeit von wissenschaftlichen Ergebnissen. Dafür können die immer noch Geld nehmen. Das ist ihr gutes Recht. Sie dürfen nur kein Geld nehmen für die Lizenzierung dieser Werke, die sie da haben. Das schließt sich einfach aus, weil da einfach die öffentliche Hand komplett geschröpft wird.
Aber führen wir doch mal genau diese Diskussion jetzt noch mal zurück, eigentlich auf das populärste Beispiel, nämlich die Musik.
Genau. Und da haben wir ein Riesenproblem.
Da funktioniert das ja nun so nicht.
Weil der Musiker von der Veröffentlichung seiner Musik leben möchte. Aber natürlich auch nur der, bei dem das überhaupt relevant ist. Und weil du eben gefragt hast, was wichtig ist, diese Auseinandersetzung, diese aktuelle Auseinandersetzung zu verstehen. Man muss verstehen, dass es einen gewaltigen Unterschied gibt zwischen den Urhebern und den rechten Inhabern. Das ist nämlich nicht das Gleiche. Ich bin Urheber, ich bin Journalist und wenn ich jetzt einen Artikel, eine Zeitung verkaufe, dann verkaufe ich die Verwertungsrechte an diesem Artikel. Das heißt, ich erlaube der Zeitung das Ding zu drucken und vielleicht erlaube ich auch noch das Ding online zu stellen und so weiter. So, wenn ich diese Verwertungsrechte aber jetzt zum Beispiel exklusiv abgetreten habe, dann bedeutet das, ich tret die ab. Also ich darf das selber nicht mehr verwerten und es gilt auch die Urheberrechtsschutzdauer. Das heißt, ich oder meine Rechtsnachfolger dürften das auch nicht bis 70 Jahre nach meinem Tod. Das ist bei meinen Texten jetzt leider nicht so interessant. Ich warte immer noch auf den Text, den ich selber schreibe, der 70 Jahre nach meinem Tod noch irgendjemanden interessieren könnte, aber so weit ist es noch nicht.
Also Chaosradio Express wird ja auch noch in 500 Jahren gehört.
Genau, insofern haben wir eigentlich eine Vereinbarung getroffen.
Das soll ich vielleicht auch mal machen.
Jedenfalls bedeutet das, dass im größten Teil der Fälle die rechte Verwerter, die Verlage, die Musiklabels, die Filmproduzenten usw. von den Urheberrechtsverschärfungen profitieren, von der längeren Dauer, also von der längeren Schutzdauer, von dem größeren Umfang, also dass mehr Werkarten z.B. geschützt werden usw. Das heißt, wir haben eine Situation, in der zwar immer in den Diskussionen von den Lobbyisten der rechte Industrie, also vom Bundesverband der Musikindustrie, vom Bundesverband der Zeitschriftenverleger, von was weiß ich wem, argumentiert wird, dass es darum geht, den Urheber besser zu schützen. Aber es geht nicht darum, den Urheber besser zu schützen, es geht darum, ihre Geschäftsmodelle zu schützen. Wovon ich jetzt noch nicht mal sagen will, dass das illegitim ist. Ich finde es zweifelhaft, dass man, also ich finde es auf eine Art illegitim, dass die es immer tun, indem sie den Urheber vorschützen, weil ich sage, das ist ein vorgeschobenes Argument. Aber das sind nun mal Interessenvertreter. Und Interessenvertreter sind dazu da, ihre Interessen zu vertreten. Nur das Problem ist, dass sie damit Erfolg haben. Das heißt, dass unsere Volksvertreter wiederum nicht die Interessen des Volks, ich will dieses Wort eigentlich nicht verwenden, aber der Bürgerinnen und Bürger vertreten, sondern dass sie sich den Schneid abkaufen lassen von den Lobbyisten in ganz vielen Fällen und Regelungen treffen, die uns benachteiligen. Die uns benachteiligen gegenüber dem, und vor allen Dingen, die auch Urheber benachteiligen. Das muss man auch mal sehen. Also das problematische Verhältnis heutzutage herrscht in erster Linie zwischen Urhebern und Verwertern und nicht zwischen Urhebern und der Öffentlichkeit. Das heißt, die Verwerter wollen immer den Popans an die Wand malen. Ja, die Tauschbörsen-Nutzer, die machen den Künstler kaputt. In Wirklichkeit machen sie unter Umständen ihr Geschäftsmodell kaputt, wenn sie es nicht schaffen, sich darauf einzustellen. Aber sie machen jetzt nicht in erster Linie den Künstler kaputt. Man kann natürlich immer argumentieren, dass Künstler, dessen Sachen in Tauschbörsen auftauchen, dass der natürlich relativ wenig Chancen hat, die Stücke noch zu verkaufen. Das ist auch Quatsch. Das stimmt ja auch überhaupt nicht. Aber weniger Chancen hat die Sachen zu verkaufen, als wenn sie nicht in einer Tauschbörse wären. Dieses weniger ist aber in der Tat sehr, sehr gering. Also man sieht ja an iTunes und dergleichen, dass Geschäftsmodelle mit Musik funktionieren können, obwohl man den ganzen Quatsch in Tauschbörsen bekommt. Es kann ja trotzdem funktionieren. Also auch da ist es mit der Empirie so eine Sache. Aber es ist eben wieder so einleuchtend erst mal, dass es ja irgendwie klar ist, wenn die Sachen alle umsonst zu bekommen sind, dass dann keiner mehr dafür bezahlt, was nicht stimmt. Das stimmt nicht zum einen. Zum anderen stimmt es eben nicht, dass automatisch die Urheber die Geschädigten sind, sondern die Urheber werden ja häufig pauschal honoriert. Das heißt, ich bekomme für meinen Zeitungsbeitrag 150 Euro und wenn ich erlaubt habe, dass der online steht, dann steht er halt online. Und wenn den jetzt 15.000 Leute angucken, statt wie normalerweise nur 250 Leute, bekomme ich keinen Cent mehr Geld. Wenn der in zehn Jahren noch abgerufen wird, weil der so spannend ist und weil der ein überaktuelles Thema behandelt, bekomme ich dafür keinen Cent mehr Geld, weil ich meine Verwertungsrechte eben in den meisten Fällen an die Verwerter abgetreten habe. Warum trete ich die in so großem Umfang an die Verwerter ab? Weil ich keine andere Chance habe, weil ich selber nämlich nicht ausreichend vom Gesetz geschützt werde als Urheber. Ich werde nicht vor dem Verwerter geschützt. Da schließt sich praktisch der Kreis zu dieser Geschichte mit diesen Geschäftsbedingungen, mit denen wir angefangen haben. Ich habe fast keine Chance, andere Bedingungen zu verhandeln, weil ich als jetzt Durchschnittskreativer, eben nicht als Günter Grass und nicht als Wir-sind-Helden, keinen Verhandlungsspielraum habe gegenüber meinem Label, meinem Verlag und so weiter, sondern ich kann nur das normale Zeilengeld akzeptieren und ich kann auch nur akzeptieren, dass diese Verwertungsrechte alle abgetreten werden. Ich selber sage zwar, das stimmt oft nicht. Man hat mehr Verhandlungsspielraum als man denkt. Also da schlagen sozusagen zwei Herzen in meiner Brust, weil ich ja auch freiberuflicher Journalist bin und durchaus auch mit anderen Freiberuflern spreche über solche Dinge und sage, Leute, ihr müsst euch wehren. Ihr müsst euch erstens zusammenschließen in Interessenverbänden, in Berufsverbänden und ihr könnt auch selber, wenn ihr nicht wirklich die letzten Lohnschreiber seid, durchaus mit euren Verlagen verhandeln, was da geht. Aber die Verhandlungsspielräume sind eben gering und diese Geschichten, die man aus der Musikindustrie kennt, bei denen also Verträge unterschrieben werden, die wirklich nur noch mit Sittenwidrig bezeichnet werden können, die sprechen ja auch Bände.
Da stellt sich natürlich jetzt auch so zum Ausklang der Sendung natürlich die Frage nach Alternativen zum Standardverwertungsmodell mit ich kauf was und dann kriege ich was. So ist ja nicht so, dass es die nicht schon gäbe. So Sachen wie die GEMA. Und dann gibt es ja auch noch diese Verwertungsgesellschaften. Vielleicht kannst du da noch ein paar Worte zu sagen. Die machen ja schon so eine Art Umverteilung.
Ja, das stimmt. Und gerade diese Verwertungsgesellschaften sind ein ganz, ganz interessantes Beispiel. Ich habe ja schon einmal erzählt, dass Deutschland auf eine Art ungute Art und Weise Vorreiter beim Urheberrecht war, meiner Einschätzung nach. Dort war es aber eine ganz interessante Entscheidung. Das war eben auch in den 60er Jahren, ich lege mich nicht auf genaue Jahreszahlen fest, aber als Tonbandgeräte aufkamen, also die auch erschwinglich waren für Privatpersonen. Und da wurde darüber gesprochen, wie man jetzt mit diesen Tonbandgeräten umgehen kann. Weil ja, im Grunde jede Kopie, das darf man ja nicht vergessen. Also eine Kopie ist eine Vervielfältigung eines Werks. Und die Entscheidung darüber, ob ein Werk vervielfältigt werden darf, steht eigentlich dem Urheber zu bzw. dem rechte Inhaber. Und jetzt wird also eine Radio, eine Symphonie im Radio ausgestrahlt und jemand nimmt sich das zuhause mit dem Tonbandgerät auf. Dann ist das zu dem Zeitpunkt, als das ungeklärt war, eine Vervielfältigung gewesen, die eigentlich der Zustimmung des Autors oder des Rechteinhabers bedurft hätte.
Home taping is killing music.
Home taping is killing music. Genau. Und das darf man ja bei Chaosradio sagen, home fucking is killing prostitution. So ungefähr. Also auf diesem Niveau befand sich dieses Argument. Und ja, aber es war einfach ungeklärt, was da mit passieren sollte. Und es gab den Vorschlag, dass praktisch beim Kauf eines Tonbandgeräts man seine persönlichen Daten hinterlegen musste, damit kontrolliert werden konnte, später, was man mit diesem Tonbandgerät getan hat. Also das waren ernst gemeinte Vorschläge, die zu der Zeit auch die Waffenregistrierung. Ja, so wie Waffenregistrierung, genau. Ich meine jetzt mal, Registrierung von Kommunikationsmitteln ist für uns natürlich einigermaßen absurd, aber zum Beispiel im Sozialismus in den Ländern des Ostblocks war das ja bis ganz lange völlig selbstverständlich. Faxgeräte und so weiter konnten man nicht einfach kaufen und anschließen, das musste alles registriert werden, Telex und so weiter, Kopiergeräte. Okay, also, da hat dann aber auch der Gesetzgeber gesagt, nee Leute, also das geht jetzt echt ein bisschen zu weit, das kann nicht sein. Und hat diesen ganz pragmatischen Grundsatz gewählt und hat gesagt, wo wir nicht kontrollieren können oder wo wir nicht verhindern können, dass etwas kopiert wird, müssen wir dafür sorgen, dass vergütet wird. Und da haben sie eben diese Erlaubnis, diese Privatkopiererlaubnis eingeführt, eine sogenannte Schranke des Urheberrechts. Da fiel mir immer ganz schwer am Anfang das zu verstehen, wieso Schranke des Urheberrechts, weil das Urheberrecht beschränkt wird. Das heißt, das Ausschließlichkeitsrecht des Urhebers oder Rechteinhabers wird beschränkt. Das ist eben nicht schrankenlos. Und ich darf jetzt nicht bestimmen, dass jemand keine private Kopie machen darf, sondern der oder diejenige darf eine private Kopie machen, aber es muss ein Ausgleich dafür her. Und da wurden dann diese Verwertungsgesellschaften erfunden und gegründet. Und da wurde gesagt, für diese privaten Nutzung oder auch für andere Nutzung, die durch Schrankenregelungen ermöglicht sind im Unterricht und dergleichen mehr, gibt noch andere Schrankenregelungen als die Privatkopie, für diese private Nutzung muss eine Vergütung stattfinden. Und wie machen wir das jetzt? Und dann wurden diese kollektiven Verwertungsgesellschaften gegründet, wie die GEMA oder auch die VG-Vort und später dann auch andere. Und was passiert? Es ist ein enorm komplexes System. Ich kenne es bei der VG-Vort besser als bei der GEMA, aber das kann man sich im Grunde genommen gar nicht so richtig vorstellen, wie das gemacht wird. Da wird zum Beispiel eine Abgabe auf Kopiergeräte bezahlt. Also jetzt diese PC-Abgabe, da haben wir inzwischen viele von gehört, weil es ja auch ein großer Streit war, weil ja auch ein PC zum Kopieren verwendet werden kann. Aber es gibt ja schon seit Jahrzehnten die Kopierabgabe, die Repro-Vergütung, die sogenannte...
Also Fotokopierer etc.
Fotokopierer eben für Reproduktionsgeräte. Und da müssen die Hersteller oder die Betreiber von solchen Kopiergeräten müssen Abgaben an die VG-Vort bezahlen. Und das ist tatsächlich gestaffelt zum Beispiel danach, ob dieses Gerät in der Nähe einer Universität steht oder nicht. Weil bei einer Universität natürlich viel mehr kopiert wird, als irgendwo auf dem Land, wo in einer örtlichen Post auch ein Kopiergerät steht, wo im Grunde genommen nie urheberrechtlich relevante Dinge drauf kopiert werden. Aber wenn das Ding im Copyshop in der Universität steht, kann man davon ausgehen, dass ganz viel urheberrechtliche geschützte Dinge kopiert werden. Und dann werden eben Abgaben bezahlt und die werden über einen bestimmten Verteilungsschlüssel an diejenigen ausgeschüttet, die eben wahrnehmungsberechtigte bei der VG-Vort sind. Das ist noch ein bisschen anders als Mitglieder. Ich selber habe einen Wahrnehmungsvertrag unterschrieben mit der VG-Vort. Ich bin wahrnehmungsberechtigter und deswegen kriege ich Geld aus dieser Ausschüttung. Und es ist, wie gesagt, unglaublich komplex.
Wahrnehmungsberechtigter?
Wahrnehmungsberechtigt. Ich nehme mein Recht wahr. Ich nehme mein Recht wahr an dieser Ausschüttung.
Aber was qualifiziert dich dafür, dass du da die Wahrnehmung... Na ich......Berechtigung...
Dass ich Autor bin in dem Fall. In meinem Fall als Autor.
Ein Autor bist du dadurch, dass du so ein Journalist bist? Also dass du einen Ausbildungsberuf abgeschlossen hast?
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. Das kann jeder. Das geht nur um die Veröffentlichung. Also das wird jetzt für die Hörer hier natürlich interessant. Wie ist es mit Online-Veröffentlichung? Das ist ein ganz schwieriges Thema und im Grunde genommen auch zum Teil noch ungeklärt. Aber bleiben wir mal bei den klassischen Geschichten. Da geht es einfach nur darum, dass man was veröffentlicht. Also sobald ich... Es gibt bestimmte Schwellenwerte, damit es nicht zu kompliziert wird. Aber ich muss eine bestimmte Anzahl von Anschlägen oder Wörtern oder so im Jahr, muss ich eben in Publikationen, in journalistischen, in meinem Fall, Publikationen veröffentlichen. Aber Bücher sind genauso, also Buchautoren sind genauso wahrnehmungsberechtigt und in Zeitschriften und so weiter. Da gibt es bestimmte Kategorien. Nee, Podcaster nicht. Also soweit ich weiß, soweit ich weiß, sind Podcaster nicht. Aber bei der VG VOD... Also bei der VG VOD...
Also Radiomenschen profitieren auch von VG VOD?
Radiomenschen, ja. Da hast du mich auch einen falschen Fuß erwischt. Aber das meine ich ja. Das ist eine unglaublich komplexe Regulierung, die da stattfindet. Wie es mit Internetradio aussieht. Und Internetradio ist ja wieder nochmal was anderes als Podcasts. Also On-Demand und so weiter. Es sind ja alles unterschiedliche Geschichten. Wie das sich damit verhält, kann ich dir im Moment nicht sagen. Also wenn ich jetzt...
Sparen wir das mal aus. Aber grundsätzlich wird von der VG VOD und von den anderen VGs, da gibt es ja auch noch andere.
Ja, es gibt die VG Bildkunst, die ist zuständig für zum Beispiel Abbildungen von Fotografien, aber auch Werken der Bildendenkunst. Also zum Beispiel Plastik, Statuen oder auch einfach Öl-Gemälden. Wenn die fotografiert werden und werden in der Zeitung abgedruckt, diese Fotos, dann fließt eine Vergütung an den Schöpfer oder an den rechten Inhaber in dem Fall.
Die kriegen ihr Geld auch über so eine Geräteabgabe? Jeder Fotoapparat oder was?
Nee, nicht über die Fotoapparate, sondern nur über die Veröffentlichung. Also wenn die FAZ, die Mona Lisa, die ist nicht oberrechtlich geschützt, aber nehmen wir mal ein Gemälde von Gerhard Richter. Also ein Bild, also ein Foto eines Gemäldes von Gerhard Richter veröffentlicht, dann bekommt Gerhard Richter Geld dafür, weil er wahrscheinlich wahrnimmungsberechtigter der vorgegangenen Bildkunst ist.
Und dann kriegt er das aber auch direkt, weil sein Bild ist genau er das Geld, oder er bekommt das sozusagen über diesen Topf, wie das bei der GEMA auch funktioniert.
Das kommt über diesen Topf. Das ist ja aber auch der Witz da dran. Das ist eine kollektive rechte Wahrnehmung. Also eben keine individuelle rechte Wahrnehmung, sondern eine kollektive rechte Wahrnehmung. Und da sind wir bei des Pudels Kern, weil ja im Grunde genommen, dass eine gute Sache ist. Also es gibt viele Kritiker, es gibt eine ganz starke Kritik an der GEMA, die Kritik an der GEMA bezieht sich nach meinem Verständnis, und das ist ja einfach höllisch kompliziert, bezieht sich nach meinem Verständnis eher darauf, wie die GEMA organisiert ist und wie dieses Geld ausgeschüttet wird. Die bezieht sich nicht grundsätzlich darauf. Also es gibt natürlich grundsätzliche Kritik an der GEMA, aber man hört ja im Grunde genommen Independent-Musiker oder auch mittelbekannte Musiker oder bis hin zu Leuten wie den einstürzenden Neubauten, die sich über die GEMA beschweren. Bei denen liegt das nicht daran, dass die sagen, es ist ein Scheißsystem, das diese privaten Nutzungen vergütet hat. Ich bin ein bisschen verantwortlich, dass die Menschen, die die GEMA verhandeln, nicht von der GEMA verhütet werden, sondern die sagen, es wird innerhalb der GEMA unfair verhandelt. Erfolgreiche bekommen viel zu viel, nicht erfolgreich bekommen viel zu wenig, es ist alles undurchsichtig, die Freiheiten sind zu gering und so weiter. Das heißt, es geht nicht um die kollektive rechte Wahrnehmung an sich, sondern es geht darum, dass die sagen, die GEMA ist schlecht organisiert.
Wie die geregelt ist und wie es konkret abläuft.
Und deswegen gibt es auch weniger Kritik an der VG VORT. Also es gibt auch da Kritik, aber es gibt weniger Kritik, weil die meisten der Ansicht sind, es ist also nicht gut organisiert, aber es ist offenbar sehr viel besser organisiert als bei der GEMA. Die Verwaltungskosten zum Beispiel sind auch viel geringer bei der VG VORT als bei der GEMA. Und dann überlegt man sich natürlich, wo kommt das her? Und wenn man dann guckt, was die Leute sich für Gehälter auszahlen und so weiter, die vorstellen, dann kann man schon mal sauer werden. Und das ist eben bei der VG VORT nicht ganz so dramatisch, deswegen gibt es da eine solche Kritik. Gut, also eigentlich ist diese kollektive rechte Wahrnehmung eine gute Idee.
Und auch diese Idee der Internetkultur-Flatrate, die ja seit langem diskutiert wird, verfolgt ja eigentlich einen ähnlichen Ansatz.
Genau so ist es. Und deswegen wird ja auch Deutschland da sehr gerne als Beispiel genommen. Weil Deutschland wirklich bahnbrechend war für diese Verwertungsgesellschaften. Das ist in vielen Ländern übernommen worden. In vielen europäischen Ländern ist das übernommen worden. Auch in den USA, da gibt es auch solche Vergütungsgesellschaften. Vergütungsgesellschaften. Ich habe das, glaube ich, eben Verwertungsgesellschaften gesagt. Das sind Vergütungsgesellschaften.
Ja, das hat er uns auch gesagt.
Ich weiß es gerade gar nicht. Ja, kann man ja alles nachhören. Und darauf wird Bezug genommen bei der Idee der Kulturflatrate, weil man sagt, ja, es geht eben genau um so eine kollektive Geschichte. Es geht darum, dass wir ein Modell finden müssen, mit dem die Schöpfer entlohnt werden können, ohne zugleich riesige Kontrollsysteme im Sinne von Digital Rights Management. Da hängt ja dieser ganze Ratten- schwanz von trusted computing dran, in Anführungszeichen. Also, dass das auch wirklich durchfunktioniert, bis auf das letzte Gerät und dass man das nicht knacken kann. Also eine unglaubliche Kontrolle, der im Grunde genommen der Inhalteindustrie über meine Geräte, die da dran hängen könnte. Bis dann hin, was im Moment natürlich diskutiert wird, Netzsperren oder selbst wenn es keine Netzsperren sind, dann sowas wie Two-Strikes. Also, dass irgendwie dann über die, also dass die Leute drauf aufmerksam gemacht werden sollen, dass sie Urheberrechtsverstöße begehen. Aber welcher Kontrollapparat dahinterstehen muss, damit das möglich ist, das machen sich die meisten eben nicht klar. Und da wird gesagt, die gesellschaftlichen Kosten sind einfach zu hoch. Die gesellschaftlichen Kosten, das analoge Modell auf das digitale Modell zu übertragen, sind zu hoch. Manche sagen, es ist ohnehin komplett unmöglich. Andere sagen, selbst wenn es möglich wäre, das Gedankenspiel müssen wir gar nicht machen, weil das, was wir dafür erzeugen müssten, an Überwachung, an Kontrolle usw., das ist einer freiheitlichen Gesellschaft nicht angemessen. Aber wir müssen auf der anderen Seite einen Weg finden, um die Kreativen zu entlohnen, weil sie unter Umständen nämlich sonst gar nicht mehr schöpfen würden.
Aber jemand dieses Problem der Überwachung und des Abzählen-Missens und Nutzungen erfassen, hätte ja auch das Modell einer Kulturflatrate, die sich jetzt sozusagen aus Internet-Abgaben finanziert.
Ja, schon. Aber auch da denke ich, das muss man ja nicht, bis auf das individuelle Musikstück und den individuellen Hörgenuss machen. Ich glaube, es wäre sehr viel einfacher, als zum Beispiel beim Fernsehkonsum zu ermitteln, was es für höherer Quoten gibt. Also wie oft ein Stück irgendwie angehört wird. Das ließe sich wahrscheinlich anonym erheben. Also wenn man den Betreibern vertraut.
Ich frage mich, was sich jetzt dafür qualifiziert, überhaupt ausschüttungsberechtigt zu sein. Weil in dem Moment, wo man irgendwie einen Teil bekommt, dann ist natürlich die Frage, okay, wer macht denn jetzt hier Kultur? Also es hatte hier vor zwei Ausgaben, CRI 162 haben wir irgendwie über Brettspiele geredet, Autoren-Spiele etc., auch so eine sehr geliebte Nische, die aber als kulturelle Errungenschaft so nicht wahrgenommen würde. Ja, wahrgenommen wird und dann auch nicht, vielleicht nicht würde, wenn man sozusagen mit solchen Modellen daherkommt. Und auch eben hier so die Problematik des Podcastings, nicht wahr? Ist genau das gleiche. Also weder will man das sozusagen unter gut Kultur, vielleicht grad noch so, aber ob das schon dann schon journalistisch ist, dann auch schon wäre so eine Frage. Also je nachdem, in welchen Topf man dann irgendwie reingehört oder nicht, es ist halt sehr schwer zu bestimmen. Und ich glaube auch, dass, ich will jetzt gar nicht so einem oder dem anderen Modell das Wort reden, aber es ist so, ich sehe einfach diese Problematik, dass sich das unter Umständen nie auflösen lassen wird. Und dann gibt es ja jetzt auch eine zweite Bewegung, die eben sagt, naja, okay, das Problem war immer so ein bisschen das Bezahlen, ja, beziehungsweise überhaupt dieses Modell, dieses Problem der Wertschätzung und auch der Unterstützung eines Künstlers. Muss denn das wirklich so schwer sein? Jetzt kommen diese Social-Payment-Systeme mit ins Feld, wie Fletter, Kurt Schingel, Weißergeier, was da in nächster Zeit noch alles mit aufs Feld kommt, die eben einfach ganz anderes Ding gehen und sagen, wir trauen es dem Einzelnen zu, auch Geld tatsächlich in Bewegung zu setzen, an etwas, was an einem großen kommerziellen Markt so nicht teilnimmt. Man muss es halt einfach nur genauso leicht machen, wie dieser Konsum leicht ist. Weil in dem Moment, wo das Kopieren und das Visualisieren, das Erhalten, das Distributieren dieser Werke so einfach ist, muss man einfach nur die Wertschätzung eben genauso schnell fließen lassen.
Ja, also ich bin in dem Sinne kein Befürworter der Kultur-Flatrate, dass ich dir jetzt aufzählen könnte, warum du in all diesen Dingen, die du gerade angeführt hast, falsch liegst, weil ich da auch große Probleme sehe. Das hat aber auch eine gewisse Geschichte. Also auch da ist es ja so, dass die Diskussion schon relativ lange gibt. Jetzt natürlich nicht so lange wie Verwertungsgesellschaften oder so was in der Art. Aber 2003 hat William Fisher ein Buch rausgebracht, das hieß Promises to Keep. Und da beschreibt er in einem Artikel, in einem Kapitel seine Idee einer Kultur-Flatrate. Fisher ist an diesem Berkman Center for Internet and Society in Harvard. Und er hat damals meiner Ansicht nach schon sehr, sehr überzeugend dargelegt, wie so eine Kultur-Flatrate in der Musikbranche funktionieren kann. Er hat da auch ein Rechenmodell aufgestellt. Viele sagen, ja es gibt keine Modelle, in denen das mal durchgerechnet wurde. Er hat das schon ziemlich gut gemacht und hat gesagt, ja, man muss eben davon ausgehen, wie hoch ist der Entertainment-Ausgaben der amerikanischen Haushalte. Also was ist das Unterhaltungsbudget? Wie viel davon fließt in Musik? Und das müsste man sozusagen umlegen auf die Kultur-Flatrate oder in dem Fall auf die Musik-Flatrate und dann kann es eben an die Künstler verteilt werden. Und dann gibt es natürlich diese ganze Kritik, die du schon genannt hast, aber wer kommt denn dann in den Genuss? Wie kommen neue Künstler an den Markt? Und er hat sich dazu gute Dinge überlegt, wirklich. Und ich habe so ein bisschen auf den Eindruck, dass jetzt, was das angeht, die Diskussion dann nicht weitergekommen ist seit 2003, dass ja auch ein bisschen enttäuschend ist. Und deswegen fand ich das auch ziemlich überzeugend damals, dieses Modell. Aber du hast insofern auch meiner Einschätzung nach völlig recht, dass das inzwischen so eine Art grenzenlose Debatte geworden ist. Das heißt, bei Fischer ging es noch um Musik. Er hat noch an Film gedacht und hat gedacht, vielleicht kann man das in Zukunft mal irgendwie noch darauf ausweiten. Heute geht es um alles. Heute geht es dann noch um Blogbeiträge. Es geht natürlich inzwischen um Journalismus, wo ich als Journalist selber ganz große Bedenken habe und mir überlege, also wenn es jetzt eine Kulturflatrate auch noch für Journalismus gibt, dann habe ich schon auch meine Probleme damit, wer verwaltet das Geld, wer bestimmt, wem es zufließt und so weiter und so fort. Ungelöste Probleme meiner Einschätzung nach. Nur wenn es wieder um die Social-Payment-Systeme geht, dann sage ich, da verliert man vielleicht ein bisschen das Problem aus dem Blick, was die Kulturflatrate lösen will, nämlich die unerlaubten Nutzungen. Das heißt, die Musikindustrie wird ja nicht einfach weggehen oder sie wird nicht einfach sagen, ja gut, dann wird halt hier für die Songs geflattert. Das wird ja nicht passieren. Und um aber diesen sozusagen Überwachungs- und Verfolgungsinteresse etwas entgegenzusetzen, muss man eben sagen, wir legalisieren das, was im Moment noch illegal ist, nämlich die private Nutzung von solchen Dingen über etwa Methoden wie Tauschbörsen oder technische Mittel wie Tauschbörsen. Und dafür muss dann aber eben auch eine Vergütung fließen. Und um praktisch da rauszunehmen, also da die Möglichkeit rauszunehmen, zu argumentieren, aber wir brauchen den dritten Korb, wir brauchen DRM, wir brauchen ACTA, wir brauchen weiß der Henker was, an neuen Möglichkeiten zu überprüfen, was Menschen tun mit ihren Medien, was Menschen tun, wenn sie Musik hören oder wenn sie Filme anschauen. Und ich fürchte, das wird nicht gelöst durch Social-Payment-Systeme.
Ja, und wenn man das zusammenschmeißt, das eine ist sozusagen, wir bilden einen Pool von Geld und dann bestimmt derjenige, der diesen Pool eingesammelt hat, wer das Geld bekommt. Das andere ist, es gibt keinen Pool von Geld, sondern jeder bestimmt selber, wo sein Geld hingeht. Wenn man das jetzt so mischt und sagt, es gibt einen Pool von Geld, aber die Leute im Netz bestimmen, wer es bekommt. Ja, dass man sozusagen nicht sein Geld ausgibt, sondern dass ich nicht mein Geld wegflettere, sondern dass ich diesen Kulturpool, der sich sozusagen ansammelt und über den ich so direkt keine Verfügung habe, dass ich den einfach mitverteile, dass ich sozusagen sage, das ist meiner Meinung nach etwas, das müsste daran mitverdienen. Das ist für mich Kultur. Und dann sagt ja der Bürger sozusagen, was er hat, auch wieder interessante Privacy-Implikationen, wenn man jetzt das erste Mal drüber nachdenkt, aber es ist am Ende auch alles lösbar.
Es ist interessant, weil ich glaube, dass es viele gibt. Ich habe immer noch in Erinnerung Müller von Blumenkron, als er noch Chefredakteur von Spiegel Online war, hat mal gesagt, ja, also ich kann auch dieses ganze Gerede davon nicht mehr hören, dass wir uns nur nach den Lesern richten und unsere ganze Policy danach ausrichten, was die Leser wollen. Wenn wir uns danach richten würden, was die Leser wollen, dann hätten wir keinen einzigen Artikel über einer Ostberichterstattung auf der Startseite. Me, weil das einfach keiner klickt. Und das finde ich interessant und beängstigend zugleich natürlich und dann in dem Zusammenhang spannend bei dem, was du jetzt vorschlägst. Also ich komme jetzt immer wieder mit so journalistischen Analogien, weil das nun mal der Bereich ist, aus dem ich komme. Das kann man sich bei der Musik und bei der Kunst genauso überlegen, nämlich ja, ich gehe zwar nicht ins Theater, ich finde es aber trotzdem toll, dass es das BE gibt oder so. Ich glaube, dass tatsächlich etliche Leute so denken und nicht einfach sagen, ja, ich höre ja nur Madonna, also kriege ich auch nur Madonna das Geld. So in dem Sinne. Das könnte ich mir vorstellen. Allerdings auch da, Empirie gibt es dazu nicht. Man kann damit auch ganz schön auf die Schnauze fallen. Am Ende gibt es eben nicht mehr das BE, sondern nur noch Britney Spears und ich weiß es nicht. Ich glaube, das hört sich so nach einer Ausflucht an, aber das ist keine. Es muss einfach weitergedacht werden. Es muss die Bereitschaft dazu da sein, das weiterzudenken. Deswegen bin ich eigentlich immer ganz glücklich, wenn so was passiert, wie die Grünen, die sagen, wir lassen jetzt ein Rechtsgutachten dazu machen, wir lassen jetzt eine Studie machen. Ist es juristisch überhaupt umsetzbar? Und dann kommt halt der Gutachter zu dem Ergebnis, ja, es ist juristisch durchsetzbar, es muss folgendes geändert werden. Und dann ginge es aber. Dann ist man schon mal einen Schritt weiter, dass man in der Diskussion sagen kann, nein, es nützt jetzt nicht einfach nur, auf internationale Verträge zu verweisen und zu sagen, die Kulturflatrate geht nicht, weil es die Berner Konvention von 1908 oder so gibt. Und wenn man dann ein bisschen ökonomische Empirien macht, dann kommt man vielleicht noch mal ein Stückchen weiter. Und deswegen will ich jetzt wirklich an der Stelle nicht sagen, ich finde die Kulturflatrate doof, oder ich finde die Kulturflatrate toll. Ich weiß es nicht. Ich kann mich nicht entscheiden. Und ich glaube, der Zeitpunkt ist auch für eine Entscheidung einfach noch viel zu früh. Was ich allerdings dann eben sehe, ist, dass an anderen Stellen Nägel mit Köpfen gemacht werden und sich das unter Umständen nicht wieder zurückdrehen lässt.
Ja, die Diskussion werden wir hier auch nicht abschließend behandeln können.
Wir haben eigentlich gedacht, dass wir jetzt alle Fragen klären in den zwei Stunden.
Es soll ja alles nur Hirn-Nahrung sein. Es müssen einfach noch mehr Leute darüber nachdenken und diskutieren. Dazu muss man auch mal alle Seiten, die gerade so in Bewegung sind, auch mal ein bisschen auf den Tisch heben. Das haben wir jetzt gemacht.
Sehr gerne. Hat Spaß gemacht.
Und ja, dem bleibt eigentlich wenig hinzuzufügen, außer dass ich mir sehr wohl vorstellen kann, dass der eine oder andere Aspekt dieser Sendung sich hier auch noch mal in einer eigenständigen Sendung verselbstständigen kann, um einfach mal hier einen weiteren Blick auf Technik, Kultur und Gesellschaft zu richten, wie ich das immer so mache, bei Chaosradio Express. Und das war es jetzt auch. Ausgabe Nummer 464 ist im Topf. Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören und bis bald bei Chaosradio Express.